[музика]
[оплески]
саме тому що студенти мають корисні
копитові умови
безперечно за наших європейських червів
[музика]
готує працівників також організації
тобто підтримання деформаційних
технологій
має програмування
[музика]
фахівці касових звіряти міжнародних
історичних джерелами і інтелектуальних
систем автоматичного керування складними
і технічних об'єктами
найважливішим завдання
м тоді дорівнює не лише для практичних
робіт лякати акваменту
техногенції функціонує
навчально-правовий розмір лабораторії
та любов господарської діяльності
закупляють цю Та затребуваністю це є
факультет енергозберігання тобто готує
конкурентну спроможних лікарів
процедувалися
підприємства
Вони часто роблять дітям 11√
працювати зокрема і творчістю
[музика]
Лісова
дочка зазначаючи свої 120 квартир
існування і ефективної підготовки
середнього роду Миколаївської
передачі з днем народження університету
привітали фашистів
з іншими країнами дієслів це зрозуміло
що допомагає нам сьогодні життєво
обов'язками
формувати більш правильну відповідь
і працює за технічними навчальними
закладами це 157 установ із 40 однієї
країни світу інтернаціоналізація
відкриває Ну і можливості для розвитку
хімії
приїхали сюди щоб відсвяткувати цей
чудовий ювілей Львівський університет
наш важливий партнер з яким налагоджено
довго тривала співпраця
з 26 повідомлю глядачам що існує
програму подвійний дипломів для
студентів про будь-яких економіки та
менеджменту я не буду конституцію
121 річниця це чудовий привід для того
аби проаналізувати результати роботи що
досягнуто і які завдання стоять попереду
Я студент четвертого курсу за 4 роки в
них побачити колосальні університеті і
найприємніше що зараз
наш бізнес на
багатьох перекрили
експертів
наших університети розвиваються
найбільше людина національного
університету біологічної України Це є
найголовніше педагогіки науковця
студентів базового закладу в Києві
відокремлених структу
рні циркування дня народження
І це не просто вся інформація презентує
свої
у якому заморожують вони повинні тисячі
студентів всі вони склали герб рідного
міста На сьогодні це все відбувається
можемо впевнено сказати що національний
університет цього ресурсний
природокористування
відвідуючі позиції у вищих навчальних
закладів України за такими
університетами майбутнє до зустрічі
[музика]
сьогоднішніми безпечного національного
університету юристи будуть пересуваємо
українською ми показуємо і Чим живе цей
навчальний заклад
зустрічає
своїх батьків перші школи
дуже цікаво
національний університет і його
результати природокористування України є
відомою престижним Одним з
найпопулярніших вищих нашої держави він
ходить у десятки кращих університетів
України та Києві Києва найбільше
населення Східної Європи навчальний
заклад
звісно за 121 рік були зелені і падіння
Успіння і невдачі але варто відзначити
що останні 5
років цинку змінюється якісні зміни в
багатьох і навчальному процесі і
організаційному виконанні репутації на
міжнарод
ний акції
після практичних університетів в цьому
році десь із тисяч краще тоді взяти
назовні групи
рослинності на 108 студентів це визнання
тому що Одна справа України
сьогодні Львів - це сучасний поліфонія
найближчий навчальний заклад
дослідницького типу тому технічне
оснащення лабораторні бази відіграють
вирішальну роль у підготовці
фахівця
будь ласка
українську конституцію
[музика]
і технології змінюють фізичні для росли
професію агронома моніторинців щоб люди
були змінити все це широко
застосовується багато цікавими спочатку
лабораторні бази що створюються спільні
університету планування і партнером
зазвичай за кордоном дозволяють
студентам більше якісно уроків
агробіологічні факультет користується
великою популярністю середньої клієнтів
адже спеціалісти цього напряму є дійсно
затребуваними на його
показувати і підготовка агрономів
студентів спеціальності
официальности студент повинен
контролювати знання починаючи з фізики
хімії екотехнології приміщення рослин
побути має бути дуже лабораторну базу і
практично власну для проведення
106 га досвіду і наявного базу
контеклор у нас своїм сучасним рішеннями
Тобто де саме в рятування навчальних
процесів використовується сучасний
період обладнання інтернет та програми
забезпечення тут готують фахівців
для реалізації державних
політиків управління земельних ресурсами
а також з розробки проектів за допомогою
проведення природних заходів здійснення
моніторингу та державного контролю за
національним використанням білковими
цілей абсолютно
користування України якась лідерів
інженерів усі страху студенти мають
можливість працювати над унікальну
екологічну оснащення цей реєстрування
поради і вас захищає і
технічні реакції музичні послуги Важливо
щоб виконати університету і це команда
оновити цього року після тривалої
перерви відроджена цікава традицію ми
наркотичного естафету у російській яйце
участь в якій беруть якісь студенти і
професійні спортсмени і хоч і
європейські педагогічний колективний
цікаво майже тисяча учасників загального
центру з дивовижних атмосферою а Ми
продовжуємо знайомити вас з факультетами
університету є комп'ютерні хвилювання та
на сайті матеріально-технічна варта для
навчання студентів наукових досліджень
одна з кращих комунікацій це сучасні
відповідні операції комп'ютерна техніка
пропущеність 3D проедерації на
факультеті працює студентів конструкції
навчальних закладах успішно працює
сьогодні
і двох кваліфікувати
юридична освіта за них унікальна тим що
ми приділяємо увагу не лише притаманним
апаратом чи має бути
економічні середину цивільному
студентів криміналістична лабораторія
зараз удома засідань маємо
відремонтований гуртожиток саме тому що
студенти мають хороші нормативні умови
Ну і безперервношення за нашими
випускниками чергами
кафедра автоматики робота технічної
безпеки економіка Мартиненка готує
фахівців кандидатів та розмірами
інтегрованих тварин має навчальну
наукові лабораторії
інтелектуальних систем автоматичного
керування складками
[музика]
громадської організації Польщі
найважливіше це зайнятості
музики він надання не лише ту
ристичних
операторів щоб вони
господарської обробки
далеко не останнє місце заправляємо в
цьому
місті готуємося до дітей або на
стандартами
студентам підприємства і бджільництва
також був частиною вони вчаться ради
сказати по-англійськи
колір майбутнього часу нормально
використано
ті унікальні політичній системі
безпекова частина обов'язкової
інструкції
[музика]
навчальними закладами
інтернаціоналізація відкриває кнопки
можливості
[музика]
для дітей
можеш зрозуміти
[музика]
співпрацю потрібно щоб підписати ме
з радістю повідомлення глядачам що існує
програма купівлі драконів
для створення Я рада вітаю
сьогодні 121 річниця це чудовий пристрій
для того аби проаналізувати результати
роботи що досягнення своєї
поперечного
[музика]
можемо впевнено національний університет
георгійський природокористування України
не випадково займає лідеруюча позиції
політики найвищою навчальних закладів
України за такими
книг до зустрічі
[музика]
потрібно відчуватися
національним університетом або
користування України ми покажемо Чим
живе цей навчальний заклад в селі
подобутком і перемогами зустрічали свою
121 річницю
України є відомого естетичного Одним з
найпопулярніших вищих нашої держави він
буде до десятки А що з університетів
України та ліків
Київської області навчальних закладах
про життя університет має виконувати
нову історію і славні традиції звісно за
121 рік підтримує падіння Успіння і
невдачі а не просто відзначити що
останні
5 навчальних закладів змінюється якісні
ігри податку і навчального процесу і
продаються оцінювання
ідентифікаційні Міжнародного дня
місцевості
Полтавської області 16
парламент це визнання газу тому що там
станів майбутнього користувалася
Сьогодні мені це сучасний кутів з
найвищий навчальний заклад
дослідницького типу тому технічне
оснащення лабораторні бази відіграють
вирішальну роль у підготовці фахівця
[музика]
змінюють фізичні для нас професій
агронома моніторинг руці і буде
провезінки все це широко застосовується
в галузі агроманії сучасні лабораторні
бази
щоб президентом і компанією партнером
зазвичай за кордоном дозволяють
студентам більш якісно обговорювати
професію агрологічно тобто
це адже спеціалісти цього напряму І
дійсно затребуваними демократії
відповідно
студентів спеціальності
студент повинен оформлювати знання
починаючи з фізики хімії до технологій
вирощування рослин тобто має форму
органу і практичну базу для проведення
бюджету студентів спеціальності
ми маємо 16
рішення мені буде з зеленим кольорів
навчального процесу використовується
сучасний
[музика]
геодезичне обладнання
забезпечення тут готують фахівців та
видатних історій основною метою
діяльності факультету як Підготовка
фахівців для реалізації державних політи
ків управління земельними ресурсами а
також розробки проектів за другою
проведення
природного здійснення культури
державного контролю за національним
використанням люди охоронної земель собі
факультезу упорядкування національної
поліції користування Україні лідерів
підготовки інженерів
студенти мають можливість прицілувати на
унікальному напрямку пошту екологічного
значення це інвестування апарати його
запускати і
походження міграційне оснащення
енергетичні приклади
важливо що колективний - це команда
композиції тобто після тривалу перерви
відроджену цікаву традицію
декларацитичному естафету або російські
місця учаться які беруть 200 студенти і
професійні спортсмени і новачки і
європейські педагогічний колектив
університету майже 1000 учасників
загальної середньої атмосферою а Ми
продовжуємо знайомити вас із
факультетами робіт одним із наймолодших
факультетів університету є факультет
конструювання та дизайну
матеріально-технічна база для навчання
студентів для проведення
ноутбука щоб виписати
їх чесність успіхів на по
рахують дітей працює студентські
конструктор
ські автомобілі вже давно не є
фотоапарати в навчальних закладом
успішно працює сьогодні і юридичний
факультет для процес навчання
здійснюється наступну політику
по-друге здобувають знання за
спеціальністю у справі
юридична освіта набір унікальна тим що
ми приділяємо увагу не лише притаманне
агра
рному екологічному право а й
адміністративного цивільному
господарському міжнародному
8 студентів криміналістична лабораторія
Саме собою засідань
будь ласка саме тому наші студенти мають
хороші побу
тові умови без перебільшення
житлобусниками черги
автоматики та робота технічна компанія
імені академіка Мартиненка готує
фахівців із атомізації та комп'ютерних
технологій має навчальну програму
і їхні виробнику фахівці з алгебри не
проводять дослідження
інтелектуальних систем автоматичного
планування
купами спорудами культури
Польщі найважливіші та сайти учнівської
школи
культури не лише практичні ознаки а ще й
практичні ігри яка буде
аквапангородський РЕ
сурсів існує навчання на уроках
економічна лабораторія від колективності
водойм господарської гімн України далеко
не останнє місце за допомогою
гарнітуру і регулює конкурентне
спроможність
лікарів студентам або
фінансово 11 коренів різних поріг
техніка полі має бути максимально
наближеному виробництва
умови пасіка апітера пластична кабінет
був такий сучасний аудиторії студентам є
з чим працювати
по наукових досліджень
оперативного світу є унікальний
механічний сад університету та Наукова
частина обов'язків Лісова
група визначаючись до 121 річниця від
дня існування колективний президент але
через директором
три
ває при народженні університету санітазу
гості видатних освітянах політичних
діячів працівники
делегації
[музика]
номер телефону
це зрозуміло що допомагає
кредитного відділення
забезпеченням навчальними закладами
тобто 57 років
світу з інтернаціоналізація відкриває
мислення можливості
ми приїхали сюди щоб відсвяткувати
шкідливості
[музика]
і це не просто вся інформація
на сьогодні 2 серпня працює
національним університету міжнародного
користування України у мене також
позиції
за такими окремими святами має бути до
зустрічі
[музика]
Одним з найпопулярніших вищих нашої
держави приходити у десятки кращих
університе
тів для трійки трійка найбільше
населення Східної Європи навчання заклад
на
уроках історії
на відпочинку
нку
які знаходяться рішення
тому технічне значення І наступного дня
Чи навчального року використову
ється дохід
у нас відбувається
моніторинг працює
широко застосовується вами є основною
спочатку лабораторній базі що створюють
різнові
університети партнером А це звичайно
дозволяє студентам більше якісну
попрацювати
Google
а е-е студентів спеціальності студентами
починаючи з фізики і літератури
має бути господарства
для доведення спеціальності
так і наявно обрахунку базу
у нас своїм сучасним рішенням клієнти
саме упорядкування навчальної фортеці
використовується сучасним сказано на
річку нам сучасна географічне обладнання
комп'ютерне та програмне забезпечення
тут готують фахівців із
нього добре фахівці для реалізації
державних
органів управління земельними ресурсами
а також розробки проектів закони
проведення природоохоронних заходів
здійснення моніторингу багато державного
контролю за національне використання
інженерів
студенти мають можливість працювати на
лікарню
цей кислотний
[музика]
оснащення фізичної культури
можливості це команда формується цього
року після роботи перерви відроджена
цікава традицію ми паразитично естафету
у процесі участь у якій беруть і
студенти і професійні спортсмени
іговички і європейських географічних
колективної університету майже 1000
учасників загальної степу дивовижної
атмосферою а Ми продовжуємо знайомити
вас з коментарями з одним із
університету збірку українських
матеріально-технічна база для навчання
студентів та проведення кнопку
досліджень одна з кращих університетів
це сучасні досить
комп'ютерна техніка
виробництва працює один із констру
кції вже неповний є такі фотографії
навчальних закладів успішно працює
сьогодні і зустрі
студенти здобувають знання за
спеціальністю в храмі юридична освіта
робіт унікальна тим що ми приділяємо
увагу на лише
економічного права і на другі
стразивному судинному господарському
режимі до 8 студентів криміналістична
лабораторія зона супроводу засідань
маємо відремонтований гуртожиток саме
тому наче студенти мають хороші побутові
умови Ми якось перемішуємо за нашу
професію особисто
[музика]
сті технічної безпеки імені
академії готові фахівців І закодимізації
такої технології маєте на бюджетно
проводити лабораторії на вулиці
[музика]
програмки інтелектуальної системи
автоматичного планування складними
об'єктами
можна і щоб завдання учні школи у
підготовці сестри тоді надає не лише
теоретичних документів а ще й практи
чних активіак
[музика]
господарської екології далеко не останнє
місце на популярність і однотягувалістю
займає професіональної медичної
підтримку спроможних лікарів ось
сподобалося
бджільництва інших пощастило вони
вчаться 11 кольорів завдяки та колір
майбутньої вчителів навчаються в
максимально наближенням виробничих
умовах справжня пасіка апітера пластична
кабінет чи будуть сучасні аудиторії
студентам є співпрацювати зокрема
гордістю наукових дослі
писати університету Наукова частина
обов'язків лісован плюси та станція
університету на чолі з директором
міста відкриває
роботу традиційно протези з днем
народження мінітрактора урочистості
гості і на яких освітян політичні вірші
зрозуміло що допомагає нам сьогодні
будь-які наукових будь-яких виробництва
сформувати якісь суперкубові
суспільства
з якими централізація відкриває емоції
можливості
ми приїхали сюди щоб ви це громада
вці Київський університет можна буде
Мазепи тільки налагоджено довготривала
співпра ця ми приїхали що під
писати адміністрацію повідомлення
глядачам що існує програма цивільних
теорію для
студентів я радий бути тут
121 річниця це чудовий провід для того
аби проаналізувати результати роботи
[музика]
що дитина
університеті і найприємніше що зараз е-е
нас університет Україна
вживається найбільше
суспільна національного університету
географії проводи
лося і педагогіки і
студентів класу в Києві від окремих
людей відбувається
презентує свої здобутки і
завершили цей випуск новиці написано у
якому заморочать вони звір 11 студентів
всі вони склали герб відповідно у
університеті
На сьогодні це все виконаючи підсумок ви
бачите кожен впевнено сказати що
національний університет
але випадково займає під ручку позиції
рейтингах вищих навчальних закладів
України
до зустрічі
[музика]
безпечного національного університету
культури природокористування України ми
покажемо Чим живе цей навчальний заклад
та назвіть видобуток і перемогами
зустрічали свою думку 21 річницю
Приєднуйтесь буде дуже цікаво
користування України Діти другим
представлені Одним з найпопулярніших
вищих нашої держави приходять і десятки
кращих університе
тів Києва найбільше населення
вулиці
що останні 5 років навчальний заклад
світло змінюється якісні зміни багатьох
напрямах і навчальних процесів для
організаційної відповідальності
громадської організації
чекаючись краще буде все
найвищий навчальний заклад
дослідницького періоду тому технічне
оснащення лабораторні бази відіграють
вирішальну роль у
побудови
Як ви бачите
вибори президента одразу
застосовується галузі звичайно ми
використовуємо що створюється срібні
компанії і партнером Зазвичай це робити
дозволяють студентам більше якісно
коментувати
професію вчитель подивитися
на тему
знання починаючи з фізики хімії до
екологічної рослин має бути лабораторну
працю і практи
чно для проведення
цілей
Тобто ми маємо 166 газу окулярів і
наявного рахунку базу
здаємо в нас
стоїть рішенням
упорядкування процесів використовується
сучасних
учасників обладнання комп'ютерних та
програмне забезпечення тут готують
фахівці вам наймиторів діяльності
факультету який Підготовка фахівців для
реалізації державної політики
інформування земельних
відноситься
з розробки проектів з
[музика]
земельного
суспільства
студенти мають можливість представники
[музика]
порушував цей республікальний апарати І
власне і
я пропустити ціною знищення фізичних
приклад Важливо щоб колективу університе
Т були 50 гривень
цікавих традицію знаєте патріотично
можна песиком голосіївській церкві тому
що які беруть 200
грн письменники європейських
географічних відкриттів
ттів майже 1000
учасників
тому ми звернула статевих об'єднаного є
функціонування
енергетичних організацій але сучасні
дослідження
та Для прикладу
успішно працює сьогодні енергетичний
факультет без навчання це здійснюється
особами знання
англійської
студентів повиненістична лабораторія
зараз область
експериментованої групи саме тому що
створити мають гроші і готові умови ми і
без перебільшуємо для нашого виборцями
карти для автоматики ремонтні
роботи
грації програми
[музика]
і цікавитись дослідження 2018
за стандар
тами студентам підприємства дуже
пощастило вони вчаться не з картинок 11
кольорів різних політичних сходів має
бути вчителі навчаються застосуванням до
кожного частини справжня пасіка абітера
графіку
є унікальні заняття для працівників та
наукових
інформаційні речі
зазвичай число 23
[музика]
.04
[оплески]
[музика]
Ой як була на на радий Чудакова тобто що
ви
думали
витягуй на всіх номерів
[музика]
максимально збільшити працювати я його
відправилась
а він уже тоді обробить міст
кість
[музика]
[оплески]
Скажіть будь ласка
[музика]
студентів спеціальності
рослини тобто має бути
практично масою для проведення для
роботи студентів спеціальності
Ви маєте 160 етапі установами і
наявності перерахунку масою вдома у нас
з цієї сучасні рішеннями і факультет
після того одягу компанії навчального
процесу наприклад стосується сучасників
тому всенародної організації сучасних
люди зійшли до влади тобто треба продати
забезпечення руху електропоїздів
основної методи діяльності акули є
Підготовка фахівців для 19 держав
них органів управління земельного
[музика]
чна відповідь
батьків
будь ласка
завдання
закінчувати для навчання сторінки вашого
керівного досліджень подорожчий
університет сучасні висновки
університетів працює студентський
конструктор
навчальних закладів успішно працює
сьогодні політичний факультет де процес
навчання здійснюється
високополітинними технологіями студенти
розвивають знання
географічної освіти автомобіль політики
[музика]
Доброго дня дорогі Мої колеги Доброго
дня шановні освітяни раді бачити
директори Департаменту території судів
учня
зі святом економічного світу
процесура вектори
очікували нас з вами збираємось наша
інвестиційна група вітає вас
сьогодні тут точно на цій площадці
зібрались всі ті кому треба байдуже
ростуть
[музика]
ми в контексті розвитку всіх наших подій
біжимо творимо формуємо
розвиваємось але забуваємо мрії
знаєте ви перед тим як почати цей форум
у нас з вами відбулась трагічна подія і
вона
життя давайте все-таки
[музика]
більше подіями життя не стоїть на місці
І більше що
освіта збирається на минуле
формується у сучасному
і
настанови йдуть на меню саме в цьому і
сильна освіта всім і Європи
на чудовому навчальному закладі
провідному університеті України що в
принципі підтверджує ще раз що освіта
України існує всіх її проява дошкільна
позашкільна технічна або перевищує вища
освіта дорослих наших улюбленцію Вітаю
вас
є вітаю вас усіх інших балок Ужгород
Вітаю вас з особистого
вже подивились
і продали
Ми чудово навчального закладі
надзвичайно подушка
базовому закладі які формує економічну
безпеку України
для задоволенням Враховуючи те що в нас
з вами семінари названу досвідом в нас з
вами
стратегічне мислення синергії інтеграція
менеджмент все те що ми з вами говорили
по всіх трьох категоріях ви формуємо з
вами про Національну університеті
біоресурсів природокористування я
задоволенням хочу надати вітальне слово
шановному ректору та великого снігу
підвищення Ніколаєнко Враховуючи те що
це і мій міністр теж
дякую
[оплески]
шановні наші гості ми з вами зібралися
який непростий час хочу сказати що це
дійсно святе місце
500 метрів більше 400 рік назад Петро
Могила поселився Тут жив а місце яке
називається голосінням це місце де
голосувало за князя воно старе молоти
скільки тут відбулося події і наші
студенти коли сюди приходять вони зовсім
по-іншому дивляться на світ Тим більше
що ми почали зараз навчальний рік Вже
ось тут перший другий курс Ви побачили
зацікавлених студентів
національного університету біоресурсів
без використання України через рік Буде
125 років разом з тим ми знаємо що він
пішов взагалі висівний конфлікт
Варшавської школи маринуті і тут
дискусія Іде
за 170 то ми поки притримуємося
концепції що ми пішли з духовкетів з
чотирьох університета КПІ
приймає іспити
уперше випуска агробіологів і там
студент похожий на Віталя Кличко успішно
складає екзамен
значить я хочу сказати що він написав
листа царевіте ліпіди значну підготовку
якісно підготовку наших агрономів
університет тут має Приблизно більше 120
території гектарів маємо унікальне
ботанічний сад 27
корпусів 14 гуртожиків за 200 тисяч
квадратних метрів студентів Сьогодні у
нас тут приблизно 13 стаціонару Ну
міняється і десь до 5 заочників всього
28 тисяч гордістю його випускники ви
бачите
після прем'єр-міністр козаченка Мельник
Лещенко Олександр
свічі приїздив це депутат Європарламенту
зараз прийшов Вже на заслужений
відпочинок від пам'ятник і сказав Я 43
роки пропрацював міністром кіпера і був
депутатом було ви
відсутність якихось знань або свою якусь
там старинність для лук який був
міністром лісогосподарства Польщі але
живкулу киристану і все законодавства
всі виразакі ніякі міністром освіти
наших самоблабський Міністр охорони
будемо казати першої Прем'єр Ну і
дівчата попробуйте свій у нас по душі
зразу згодом богдаренко вона Де так
очолює Думки якісь області наша
енергетика сказано включає
дорогі друзі Хочу сказати що університет
переживає надзвичайно складний час ми
успіх свій намалювали Голосіївський
ініціативи 2025
сформовано ми вже перше п'ятирічку
пройшли там 10 складових але основні
такі це зв'язок з бізнесу потужний
зв'язок між потужним міжнародні зв'язки
міжнародні зв'язки
і зв'язок із
і робота із кращими вченими світу і
України ці три складові дають нам
можливість вирішувати багато задач Ну я
вам хочу сказати що по скажімо рейтингам
усім Ми з топ 2008 якщо взяти навкрутку
складу комітетів в Україні тому в цьому
році Бачите як наші місця але Це також
важливо те що сьогодні ми намагаємося
дослідництво переплести з о
світні Недавно ми слухали навчальній
раді як працює технологічний факультет
серед було приємно
пов'язаних з даним великим глибокими
аналізами по вітру і так далі студенти
дуже проективну участь і все там дає
право говорити про те що ми сьогодні на
двох університет має три інститути
навчання наукових 13 факультетів і хочу
сказати що в цьому році ми мали 25 тисяч
заяв нам не дораховують вступ на базі
коледжу а в цьому році ми тільки
замовлені мали 1220 школи і 550 на базі
коледжа взагалі от штуку приблизно 3,5
тисячі прекрасні ребята дівчата юнаки
хочу сказати що ми знаходимо спільну
мову з нашими студентами активно працює
студентський самоврядування маємо
прекрасний викладачів на аспірантури
температури працюємо і сьогодні маємо
500 у нас
420 лабораторій надзвичайно складна
штука Сьогодні ми побачили кілька для
того щоб проходити система господарством
без зв'язків з виробництва та
розбізнесом і не участі в рамках
міжнародних проектах ми нічого не мали
тому що це дуже-дуже не просто бюджет
університету з відокремленим структурним
підрозділами зусиль це приблизно 1,6
млрд грн але із них на відміну від
Шевченка наприклад да по інших із них ми
тільки своїми силами заробляє приблизно
700 мільйонів видно задіяністю 250-300
мільйонів це те що ми самі заробляємо
кошти для студенти працюють викладачі і
так далі І так далі ми маємо гарну
міжнародну співпрацю 12 дипломів
подвійних із провідними університетами і
Німеччини Франції Польщі Америка зараз
Назар зупинилась зв'язку з нашими
міського відділення
Ну і працюємо дуже цікаво зараз хочемо
відкрити в Китаї в селі Миколайович
філію свої патріот спеціальності
ветеринарному жити саме харчових
технологій і менеджмент до цього йдемо я
думаю що ви побачили число нашого
територію Ну і Закінчую свій короткий
виступ таким гаслом який написав Василь
[оплески]
дуже дякую давайте ще раз прокладуємо
[музика]
добрий при душі природні зони
на уроці
і дорогою рушили лише
[музика]
тиск Христовим
все Що малюють
[музика]
Братан ти чесно
мене і свій Коли ти пісню солов'я
і пшеничне
[оплески]
[музика]
питання до пісні
тобі
Господи себе родини
[музика]
очах
осі
б Даю тебе щаслива дня
скобу яйця
[музика]
завжди
що хоче сказати
з вашого дозволу
хочу бачити слайди буду на місці
казати Мені дуже приємно було що коли
студенти викладачі презентували технічні
там де
Я думаю що від нас всі вже гарний
настрій ми можемо переходити дорогу
перед тим як починати
певний аналіз хочу подякувати всім
директора
Департаменту освіти за рідкою цього року
форум має стати для менш важливим ніж
наша особлива конкуренція але земної
групи поставили два місяці так сьогодні
є підсумки аналіз І що ж ми маємо робити
далі почнемо
аналізуючи те що в нас відбувалося
попередній озеленим ознаменували цей рік
ми дещо
дослідив в нашому випадку І напередодні
нового року я вже казав думаю обліпити і
разом всі з вами згадати нашого
майбутнього
Ми сьогодні формуємо
найкрічущі питання з найбільш
масштабного проекту який відбувається в
Україні приборонтології української
школи
ви сьогодні ділимося з вами розчином
спільно визначає подальших років
формуємо наше майбутнє а саме головне
майбутнє нашої дітей які будуть
формувати майбутнє України
найважливіші завдання які ми з вами
маємо поставити один до одного і це все
дякуючи своїм колегам керівникам
Департаменту
до спільно визначили їх два
все виконати забруднення сьогоднішнього
суспільства це перше і друге створювати
людські капітанами
адже ми з вами розсіюємо ми всі прийшли
на нашому
хворого і презентації освітнього
технопарку у двох на дві тести на
території України всеосвіті науковий
проект
Україна - це освіта науковий проект
території України серед наукових і до
цього ми маємо йти а йти ми маємо
сільським капіталом
годуючись до зустрічі з вами і разом з
вами пам'ятаємо проаналізувалося що
відбувалося
І без перебільшення можемо сьогодні
на базі ініційованих вами з вами робили
робити бендерів Я хочу дуже подякувати
з цим колегам Міністерства Щоби сказати
відповісти на нього
своїм колегам історію біологічної освіти
незалежних інституцій громадських
організацій батькам соус які активно
хворіли участь у цьому проекті що дало
нам можливість виокремити найуспішні
питання які є сьогодні у конкурентні
реформи української школи ми з вами
виступили нас сиделії інтеграція
мешканці якої Тесли з вами маємо
ефір і ті самі 7 вже сьогодні
окреслилися
маленькі новини які вже яскраво граємо
Та деяких територіях І сьогодні ми
почуємо всі ті Мелодії від деяких
територій які вже активно починають
домінувати на території України усі інші
треба підтягуватися
учасники опитування
це учні і батьків вчителі так керівники
заклади освіти просто громадяни нашої
країни незалежно від тих професійних
освітніх експертів які були доручені до
цього і це є можливість це для
презентативність виборців що показує нам
з вами можливість подальшого руху
отже
перший показник на якому має акцентувати
увагу це загальне ставлення громадянства
і в цьому загальна уставленні ми бачимо
з вами більше 50 майже 50 гривень
учасників розглядають освіту як велику
це місце наша з вами спільна перемога що
ми за весь цей час все ще 50% більше ніж
50% населення розглядає розслідування
багато часу
має цей показник нас тішити Чи непокоїти
це велике питання
і ми маємо тішитись Що більше частина
суспільства все-таки сприймає освіту Ми
пам'ятаємо 90-ті роки всі пам'ятаємо
коли освіта перетворилась не в цінність
А в те що просто пустоїв простої драка
часу на сьогодні в нашому з вами
зусиллями
спілкуючись усіма своїми колегами зі
сходу до Західної півдня до півночі ми
всі хочемо цей показник бачити краще і
ми всі до цього докладаємо
на це Чи все ми зробили безумовно не все
безумовно Це тривалий процес адже у
світі є лише інфраструктурні і цифрові
швидкі перемоги А змістовні і
викладацькій кадрові Вони занадто
довкілля 12 років викладацький теж
вчителя треба готувати або про це все
знаємо
трохи знають будь ласка дай проблеми ще
показник оцінка якості національної
освіти
на другу більшості майже 52%
освіта є посередньою
20 майже 25% вважає її військовою І лише
кожен 10 тобто 10% вважає її як високо
теж задовольняють нас всіх показники на
ручний
ми всі роки але знову-таки пам'ятаємо
кадрові з історії Перемоги дуже довго
від того що ми закладемо зараз ми
отримаємо через лише тих проміжок часу
Ми так само приблизно виглядає і за
рейтингами результатами міжнародного
дослідження і
спілкуючись в серпні місяці з керівником
дослідження 50 у Європі ми про це
говорили
варіації показники непокоїть а висновок
рік і було саме в цьому Ми поставили
весь наш подальший аналіз
щоб виявити корінні проблеми і
напрацювати реальні механізми
реформа нової української школи є
подальших кроків нашої з вами країни
І сьогодні ми стартуємо не просто школа
ми стартуємо великий агломерації освіти
Ми стартуємо з дошкілля
працюємо разом з позашкіллям не може
бути реформа школи виокремлена від
загального освітнього процесу
і жодна реформа при цьому Треба
враховувати те що нема на 100% населення
тому що всі люди різні
ті оця різати різноманіття додає нам
можливість в нашому процесі вносити ті
корективи які дають нам покращення
якості адже доступність якість
більшість суспільства прагне
стабільність і будь-які зміни нам з вами
дають певний суспільство диссонанс або
резонанс або інтенсинцію або ще якісь
переважні якості Але в цьому в цьому і є
реформа
ви знаєте На мою думку є дві катего
рії спільних
значущіх таких подій ці освітній футбол
то який долучені всі
адже хто краще забиває голи
вболівальники або на трибуні як ми перед
екраном телевізора і на екран телевізор
виприскується весь цей Негатив який є на
мене на кожного з вас про регіонах у
всьому іншому той Хто вчився в освіті
хоча б в школі він має він вже відчуває
себе фахівцем освіті
хтось прочитав буквально хтось може
фахівець у світі
Але в цьому професійному освітньому
середовищі наша сила експропозиційна
освітнього і експертному середовищі я
можу вдячний що до нас приєднався з
ручки це громада наша академії
певнах які підставив плечі разом з усієї
академією Просвітництва експертним
середовищем важкий для нас час
підготовки базового стандарту
і ми з честю Дуже дякуємо вам витримали
цей цей ну такий важливий іспит в нашому
з вами був
за даними дослідження Національної
академії наук понад 67% наших громадян
підтримують необхідну систему
підтримують необхідність якому
національної системи освіти Але разом з
тим 56% в принципі не уявляють суті
нововини нової української школи
це не ранкова зустріч - це не меблі Це
не ті не тільки меблі не тільки ранкова
зустріч а тільки Lego хоча б підписали
вже вдячний заливну функцію
це перш за все хай буде вчити носії
змісту трошки забув Добре що є
українська служба оцінювання якості
освіти разом з присутній тут коли
сертифікаціям вчителів відбувається на
найвищому стандарті Сьогодні ми вживаємо
понад тисячу осіб які своїм досвідом
готові поділитися є носіями освітньої
дипломатії в регіонах і росіянами
культурно-освітніх традицій в цілому по
Україні
що це означає
56% людей які не уявляє сутність Нового
року ми мабуть не до кінця комунікуємо
суспільство
я прошу
дуже прошу юнісефна з цього активно
підтримує ми вчора отримали надзвичайно
підтримку від дитячого фонду тривоги
ісед щодо комунікаційної підтримки всіх
освітніх університетів які мають
відбуватися наша держава
всі будь-які новації всі будь-які події
які відбуваються в тому числі в регіоні
Просимо Вас наполягаємо вас інформацію
щодо Преступности
ства
щоб відключили цей холерів будь-яка
реформа буде стояти
а саме батьки місцеві громади і в
принципі все суспільство будь-які
заявлені інновації будуть Лише
проголосію будуть лише слова
це є там дуже велика велика
незрозуміння і вчителів і батьків
згадує дослідження показує що
регіони є різні це правильно є більш
сильні я більше успішні запровадження
для хворого є трішки ті в яких
суб'єктивних причин ці реформи не можуть
рухатись на швидко і тому що є умовно
кажучи ну обрізки
але ми маємо всі ділитися досвідом
і
підтримки переважної кількості
громадян України в будь-якій реформі
нема Та очікувати але варто рухатись за
даними кульками наших
спорт ми маємо ще більш тривожна
ситуація дослідження Національної
академії вірного суду організації змісту
освіти констатують Наступне Що Не
дивлячись на потужний матеріальний
забезпечення ще не відбулося підвищення
якості відповідь очікуваної підвищення
якості результатів початкової школи
Це так воно є усі про це знає про
особливе значення колегами суторної
клінічної освіти десь говорити декілька
разів наполягали на цьому вони сьогодні
одні залишились на корпусці підготовки
вчителів професійної підготовки Сьогодні
мають
але чи всі професійні чи всі якості чи
всі змістовні чи всі наповнені тією
самою глибиною вчителя оце питання
наше питання нам з вами до всіх
чи варто відправляти на підвищення
кваліфікації
можуть готувати всі товариства приватні
підприємці які мають ліцензію все інше А
зріст глибина наповнення подальшої дії
Хто з вас хотів би піти до структури
речення
стоматолог який готувався на наприклад
не болгарський стоматологічної академії
а десь відкрилось
вони є містечко десь там все інше
хтось хотів би йти готуватися до
початківців ремонтуватися
А ви б хотіли би коня віддати того
вашого високоохоронністю
першого курсу на Національний банк Я
думаю що не виконуються
безумовно маємо діяти діяти скрізь не
випускати руху дії для рухатись вперед
гострики необхідні колективі в наших з
вами електронного коли ми говорили і
просили всіх інших
підприємств зробити такий у акцентів на
який ми з вами маємо спиратися і який
перелік семінарів рамках нашого з вами
навколосвітня технологіях мають умову
кажучи і
звичні наші з вами
звички традиції і закінчують але
це прекрасно наприклад освітня історія
як ми бачимо насправді
почав дітей і що казав
школа вчительці те що про нас завжди
говорить і завжди наголошують
людину а тут вчительцентризм навколо
школу провідності знань він базова
ступінь того що ми з вами про який буде
вчитель те саме ми маємо очікувати від
суспільства
категорія зараз про третій який на думку
показники є учнів це навчання
якість освіти є наша головним завданням
саме головне питання для нас всіх як їм
повернусь не існує універсального
концерту
в червні презентували модель
національно-освітнього Прикарпаття з
приміщення якості освіти А сьогодні ми
свої колеги послухаємо які моделі
створена на місцях цих особливостей
розвитку які успіхи які вже президентами
Харківська область наживо Вітаю вас
на місця створення освітньої хати які
наближують всю територію України до того
самого освітнього руху
бачити які вже функціонують реальну
функціонування Я пишаюся дякую вам
шановніку
інтерпретація дитячих вподобань в школі
очима батьків виглядає так Прошу
подивіться цікаве дослідження
і на першому місці розвиток дитини який
має разом школу забезпечувати і
позашкільні заклади те про що я казав і
як у разі позашкільної освіти немає і
буде знищена це додатковий розв'язок
офлайн і онлайн соціалізації здобуття
додаткових навичок ми маємо розглядати
це все в контексті розвитку школи
розвитку освіти школи в широкому
розумінні слова школи як школи Життя це
і освітня і громадська і патріотична
складова недаремно статислав Ковач
презентував і особливо показав роль
військової кафедри в університеті це
школа
школа захисту
гостей запитання до окремих громад яких
в першу чергу відбувається
бездумна реорганізація і ліквідація
оптимізація має бути але має бути
економічно
обґрунтована і погоджена з батьками
треба не просто ліквідувати школу а
показувати що дитина при ліквідації при
оптимізації мережі а буде набагато
більшу якість
природи щенок Дуже дякую за те що ми 70
шкіл оптимізували у вигляді
Чернігівській області вона нескладна
вона сама після Одеської найбільше по
території але найменший був останній
населення І звісно що в школі на 35 на
70 дітей
неможливо забезпечити діяльність освіти
яка може бути в школі на 400 500 600
дітей це безумовно але але але так як ви
зробили регенерацію в цьому році вона
мені зразком Дуже дякую
Отже проблематика реформи очима батьків
виглядає приблизно так не розуміє
скасування звичайного бального
оцінювання
червона ручками завітає Адам чого там
Руської правди це все Я вчора був із
шкіру дуже велика школа 740 дітей
червона ручка є майже однаковий
поділяється питання ставлення до
зменшення чи відсутності домашніх
завдань
і вкрай ретельно проаналізувавши
змістових підручників завдяки пандемії
письмові сушки пропозиції твоїх
покращення і ви їх сприймаємо
зовсім змінина процедура порядок порядок
сьогодні відбору і другу підручників
зовсім звільнений контекст взагалі
підготовки цих підручників і я дуже
сподіваюсь що в нас в такому бюджеті на
22-й рік ми дитині ви отримали але
хибрючні Які в нас буде все гаразд
приходимо до складу восьмого ставлення
батьків до скасування осіб
Це дійсно проблема на яку звертає учні
батьки вчителі це проблема оцінювання і
всі досліджуйте включаючи проведення
команду інтересні Дякую вам за ретельний
аналіз цього всього визнають цю проблему
одна з іншого і наявна ситуація змушує
нас перевіряти оці підходи не в бік їх
скасування Ах ти їх вдосконалення вбік
їх
напрацювання найбільш дієвих і фах
більше
сучасних методик до цього підходу жодна
реформа немає стояти жовтий процес немає
стояти це як стояча вода возити або
видання
Струмочок тоді вона обговорюється їх
дуже з вами казали всі маємо це розуміти
і всі на цьому стоїмо вчителі і лідер
нації і Літо має готувати
саме ті такого з органу ми маємо
відштовхуватися і Від цього залежить
майбутнє нашої з вами про культуру
в центрі уваги нової української школи є
вчитель як все своє життя писало Василь
в школі є основний основи і формує наше
з вами подальше того
із цього саме з цього сховано саме з
цією тези ми переходимо у потребі зразок
і нашими інститутами різноманітних
програмних хто ключовим перекваліфікації
підвищення кваліфікації вчителів Далі
будемо системи підготовки вчителів на
сьогодні
вони трошки переформатовані по
заступникам у них Всі один полісівник
тому що на сьогодні ми сьогодні говоримо
про 22 і 47 тисяч локацій то До чого
дійшли нас з читання немає
у нас немає вчителя добре що сьогодні
існує онлайн всеукраїнська школа онлайн
яка дає змогу непрофільному вчителю
підготуватись до тих чи інших тестів
вийти з одного боку духовного до певного
рівня хоча б дійти до цієї функції але в
цілому це є проблема
ми з вами всі разом запровадили
економічну мобільність історичної
літератури стажування між іншими
закладами в тому числі в університетах і
це теж було презентовано і на серпневі
конференції і на презентації технопарку
і сьогодні наша Миколая буде
презентовано дуже цікаві яскраві
приклади деяких за основу інакше нічого
побудуємо
окрему уваги я вже згадував сьогодні
потребує сертифікації вчителя
сертифікація вчителя якщо прагматично
вказати це єдиний інструмент який він
сьогодні дає можливість власним розумом
отримати 20% заробітної плати взагалі
розраховуючи тільки на себе Скільки в
нас на сьогодні вже є по сертифікації
1677 році 1607 якщо в минулому було 920
а в цьому році
тисячі вийшло 13
фінал минулого 92 це дуже пристойні
показники але мало
запитайте в своїх колег запитайте
вчителя чому
якщо є побоювання того що складний
процес давайте семінари Давайте
роз'яснемо давайте показувати але
сертифікований вчитель
сертифікований вчитель набагато більше
Зробить для наших з вами дітей і її
фахівцем який спроможний генерувати ідеї
до змін
ці завдання вирішуються не тільки
державну службу якості освіти Ми
сьогодні поставили таке саме завдання
наших героїчним мистецтво
які мають разом з інститутами
Північної освіти формувати концепцію
сертифікат з підвищення кваліфікації
сертифікації вчителя
багато проблем які
стосуються нашого з вами забезпечення
давайте перейдемо до розгляду аналізу
використання коштів у студентів
нова українська школа велика державна
субвенція а спрямована на захист всіх
фігурок спрямована на підтримку освіти
лише сім обласних закладів культури
педагогічної освіти проводять підвищення
кваліфікації за програмою нова
українська школа
скажіть іншим не треба
Чи у вас є якісь перешкоди чому не
працює зробіть вона староста коли
зробіть біля опитування чому чому
кількість сім'ї Чому всі інші Чому ви
віддаєте або ви ринок віддали і тоді ви
не
матеріал в роботі цього Або чому так
стається шановні керівники дебернарників
грушу вас проаналізуємо
і поміняйтесь досвіду звернутись процес
мабуть
найближчою до нас до всіх до керівників
це є менеджмент у світі
Саме від нас з вами залежить стратегічне
значення була планування організації
роботи в нас всіх а від того як ми
склали організуємось як я побачила
перспективу залежить і Коли ми ставимо
клас і він від цього саме залежить всі
групи всі відповіді на ті виклики які є
ви тоді багато але кожен виклик ми маємо
перетворювати на можливість
ще раз повернусь до використання
субвенції загальний показник складає
47,4
а лише 47,4 Ну скажіть будь ласка кошти
вже не потрібні
виходимо від громади до громади запрошую
тему Що казати постійно
Давайте говорити
Він дуже жорстко відслідковий а також
жорсткіше ніж Міністерства освіти
може якщо не потрібні кошти при
перерозподібних нагрудного методу
з успішною користуються програми цю
шкільних автобусів ще одне річуще
важливе питання
можна було придумати що вони його
показниками повністю задоволені потреби
в шкільних автобусів
можливо це проблема з утилізацією мережі
або інші проблеми я прошу звернутись цей
аналіз стаціонарську шановній території
[музика]
окрема проблематика
щодо субвенції порушує взяти біля
особистої
у нас також дуже є
яскраві
експериментальні проекту
які сьогодні озвучують наші дороги
Візьміть ці за основу поділіться досвіду
давайте створимо ще якісь у нас
додаткові семінатор
і саме по
враховуючи важливість такої категорії як
менеджменту Ми сьогодні формуємо
організацію Міністерства освіти і науки
щодо створення національної школи
резерву управлінських кадрів
всі дивуються
одна тільки використовувати мені
інформацію
ми можемо встановити У нас є всі права
на нас
і ще одну інновацію нашої яку ми хочемо
в рамках розвитку цих подій по
менеджменту це вдосконалий управлі
нський із цього року ми з вами
запроваджуємо систему освітніх
управлінських і інтегралів
це система оперативного управління яка
буде оперативно давати надавати
інформацію для всіх керівних дій
Нас звати Як менеджер
Сьогодні ми колеги будуть представляти
інші до вас прошу дітей відбути
ці презентації і
Закликаємо у вас там лідер дискусій
до яскравого обговорення не стесняний
задавати наймостріші питання
мозковий штурмом багато чого зможемо Але
після мозкового збуту дітей 15 нас з
вами діти ще раз діє Дякую вам З повагою
до вас найкраща побажання оскільки
[оплески]
[музика]
Шановні колеги Ми продовжуємо з вами
презентаційну платформу
і
доповіді міністра Ми запрошуємо наші
рекорди це наші інститути запорошуємо
директора інституту модернізації змісту
освіти і для виконавча До побачення
Володимировича
це економічна голова парламентської
комісії
я що хочу звернутися підтримати вас то
обережного реформування мережі
Це дуже добре як виглядає 21 000
сьогодні 15 Це було зроблено напередодні
доросла
але я був в робочій групі ми не
запросили я випадковому робочій групі
тому обговоренню положення про ліцей
знаєш стрілочку Я не бачу України
які пишуть положення кажуть Та що це
ліцей буде в кожній Грома
ді буде приватизація якраз дискримінації
і так далі так у нас громада у Мукачево
80 тисяч у місті і 120 навколо то що
всередині цей на 120 тисяч
У моєму селі 8 тисяч населення але для
відділі які якщо ми не будемо мати
ліцеїв і не надати носиться в сторону
треба доступність до освіти якісної
забезпечити і громади сьогодні величезні
Херсонської області 26 було 16
не буде доступ ми просто тому середовища
правильно поставили в центрі я як голова
грати освітян і науковців України і
власне ця цигарного
роками скільки треба вас багато
депутатів щоб це саме реалізовувалось на
місце
шановний Шановні колеги Шановні
агромістр шановний директори шановний
президент академії педагогічному дуже
приємно і дуже відповідально тому що
взяти три міністра освіти присутні Які
останні 20 років
керувались керують освітою і ми
знаходимося сьогодні
на шляху модернізації на шляху створення
нових проектів про які я сьогодні вам
хочу презентувати я розкажу вам сьогодні
Шановні колеги про декілька проектів про
конкретно про чотири два з яких
успішно реалізуються і два проєкти про
які один з яких сказав Сергій
Миколайович - це національна школа
резерви управлінської кадрів розкажу вам
про концепцію цього проекту
запросимо декілька
спікерів які скажуть пару слів і
дуже цікава інноваційно-освітній проект
моделювання інтегрованого освітнього
цифрового середовища атмосферна школа а
почну Я з проекту який називається
здорова Україна
цей проект
Він знаходиться під патронатом
президента України
головна мета цього проекту це
здорове освітня безпечне середовище в
школі
останній міністр який займався і
опікувався фізкультурою в школі це був
Станіслав Миколайович
І от сьогодні нам дуже приємно що
особливо президента на контролі це
питання і за останні декілька
місяців зроблена
зроблена велика робота ви знаєте що
прийнятий державний стандарт базової
середньої освіти
який сьогодні пілотується
140 школах і з наступного року п'ятий
клас йде дуже поганому по стандартами
української школи п'ятий клас на
виконання цього була розроблена модельна
програма з фізичної культури
запрошені найкращі фахівців України з
міністерства спорту федерації з різних
видів спорту науковці університети і
створена єдина програма на підставі якої
розробляється новий Урок фізичної
культури
змінюється принципово підхід змінюється
сама філософія цього року
передумовою цього було створення
були рекомендації всесвітньої
організації охорони здоров'я від 2018
року
відповідно до яких
рекомендовано що
дітям у віці від 5 до 17 років
щонайменше
потрібно 60 хвилин на день фізичного
навантаження помірної і високої
інтенсивності
І от постає питання де взяти 60 хвилин
на день коли в школі в нас один два
уроки або три роки на тиждень
фізичної культури і тут ми
взяли досвід успішний різних проєктів в
тому числі
Джуніор Z Олександр педаль який є
сьогодні теж провідником цього проекту
взяли досвід
іноземних країн взяли всіх всі ті цікаві
види спорту які можна було адаптувати
під любий сучасний урок фізку і таких
вийшло в нас 45 модулів
з яких
вчити порадившись з дітьми з батьками
ураховуючи наявну матеріально-технічну
базу закладу освіти
враховуючи фізичний стан медичний
показання медичні групи можуть обрати
вид спорту які буде відповідати
інтересам тієї чи іншої людини
наше завдання
повернути інтерес зацікавленість дитини
до групової активності
знищити цю ганебну практику коли
беремо довідку і не йдемо на фізкультуру
займаємося своїми справами урок
фізкультури має бути цікаво Наша команда
лідер цього проекту Галіна коломоєць є у
нас за людьми
вони вже об’їхали декілька регіонів і
тільки за два місяці три тисячі вчителів
виявили зацікавленість і пройшли треки з
ними їздять тренери з ними їздить
Олександр Педан їздить
спортивний Федерації і допомагають
вчителям навчитися анатолітися новою
викладання
фізичної культури і
один з найголовніше теж компонентів це
ми хочемо відійти від
[музика]
має бути головний принцип - це розвиток
фізичної якості
Це найголовніше принципово кожна дитина
різна Кожна дитина має свої особливості
наступним проектом здорова Україна є
компоненти дій називається
реформа теж державного харчування це цей
проект в рамках здорової України
знаходиться під патронатом першої Леді і
задіяно в цьому проекті величезна
кількість міністерств цей Міністерство
охорони здоров'я Міністерства освіти і
державне споживча служба і мені інститут
модернізації змісту освіти відповідаємо
за методологію за наповнення цієї
платформи вона найближчим часом буде
презентована зараз відбувається
конференції по всій країні на цій
платформі ви всі знайдете від вчителя
від завідуючого
встановлюють
ректора Департаменту будь-хто знайде для
себе інформацію
складовою здорової України є індекс
здоров'я школи
це індекс започаткований інноваційному
освітньому проєкті
всеукраїнського рівня він складається з
8 компонентів
ця модель діє школах Дніпропетровської
Львівської Полтавської Рівненської та
Херсонської областей
модель здорової школи поєднує 8 ключових
компонентів коли їх можете бачити на
екрані
як використовувати результати індексу
здоров'я на основі отриманих результатів
команда закладу освіти розробляє план
досконалення які містять пріоритетні дії
перелік необхідних
ресурсів та заходів розподіл обов'язків
між виконавцями і терміни їх виконанням
результати оцінки можуть стати
аргументом необхідним для отримання
підтримки від громади та пошук
додаткових ресурсів найближчим часом
індекс здоров'я школи будуть
інформаційні системи Міністерства освіти
і науки і доступ матиме всі заклади
освіти
наступний проект який був
започаткований і
запущений в цьому році це всеукраїнський
проект про реєстрацію даного будову
кар'єру це
я попрошу на їх Богуславку нам буде його
не спробувати глядача коротко розповість
але два декілька слів скажу що Ми навіть
самі не очікували що буде така
зацікавленостей
Понад мільйон переглядів
за два місяці
поворот розподіляції одночасно
подивитися понад 500 тисяч учнів це був
зафіксований навіть рекорд України і я
думаю що це платформу що цей проект ми
будемо тільки вдосконалювати і з
наступного року ми профорієнтацію
зробимо
щорічним на початку навчального року
Скажіть будь ласка
Стрітення потім всюди коли бажаємо
Україною аеропорції від вашого
спілкування була привела вас на все
добре
[оплески]
[музика]
і допомагають військовим здібності і
спланувати подальше навчання і майбутнє
України на жаль в Україні враження
тому що на жаль не можуть дозволити на
цьому літати свої такі кошти через що ви
складається
частина про комунікації на цьому
прикладі перший крок - це система
тестування абсолютно безкоштовний пробне
дуже якісний інвалідний короткий текст
адаптивний який Всього за 30-40 хвилин
інформацію щодо таких особистості і
інтелекту і за допомогою цієї інформації
згенерує ті професії які Кожна дитина
має вже зрозуміти так нещодавно цей
реєстр отримав також відповідність
розумної інформації
завдяки цьому проекту тепер Кожен учень
нашої країни зможете відвідувати
успішні підприємства у вашому сучасну
професію умови як революціонування руху
а далі вірно з консультантів що от мм
тобто на е-е за результатами його
складається кадрове резервний
талоновіших людей молоді які достатньо
працювати в тій чи інші спеціальності у
кожної дитини є на сайті і особистий
профорієнтаційний список портфоліо його
здібності талантів і професій і звичайно
інформацію з людей як в звичайному
люментом
і для роботодавства це є величезною
перевагою і таким елементом для
накрутинку і ви можете побачити зараз на
екрані
партнери які вже користуються ці
предметами які долучилися до нього за що
ми дуже вдячні і вам регіону теж
затвердження для фінансових сусідів то
був з 2014
Дякую колеги і у зв'язку з тим що в нас
небагато часу То я хотів би одну тезу
сказати щоб на цей проект ми подивилися
більше щоб вони перспективів
27-го року коли має бути започаткована і
введена в старшу профільна школа так
оцей інструмент має допомогти дитині в
середній школі більш визначитись знайти
себе протестувати себе і подивитися і
обрати ту професію який вона відповідає
а не вчитися які працювати потім кидати
роботу іти в Державний центр зайнятості
відповідно навчатися і так далі наше
завдання залишити центр зайнятості без
роботи
так коротко
і розкажемо про анонсульство
дуже цікавий і дуже амбітний проект
братів в кінці свого виставку сказав
міністр Він про нього в Харкові
називався але за ці декілька місяців ми
вам презентуємо концепцію цього проекту
це національна школа резерву
управлінських прав
декілька тижнів назад один з керівників
департаментів розказав ситуацію коли на
конкурс директора школи прийшли декілька
осіб 4 чи 5 з яких було
два директора з досвідом роботи
керівників і вони не пройшли
А чому не прийшли а вони не здали
законодавство тобто уявляєте собі що де
брати попрацював там 5-10 років школі не
не здав законодавства це говорить про те
що є в нас управлінці з досвідом але
яким не вистачає сучасних знань сучасних
навичок і от головна мета цього проекту
- це
сам мені пошук і підтримка потенційних
лідерів це мотивування їх до кар'єрного
зростання це підготовка резерву
управлінських кадрів з числа
вмотивованих претендентів на посаду
керівників це можуть бути і діючі
керівники і в заступники які хочуть
стати успішними і Пройти навчання
особливості програми дуже коротко тестів
ЗНО це
змішана система це
номер один у світі формат онлайн курсів
з корм
спростовують більшість більшість не
успішніших
кейсів практичні кейси які допоможуть
керівникам керівникам реальних ситуаціях
певні там така ситуація впевнена
приймати найкращі рішення стажування
стажування на провідних навчальних
закладах
керівником цього проекту є Наталія
Іванівна Хлопець будь ласка хреноваться
вони будуть на щось безкоштовно нададуть
багато своїх програм
є цікаві є цікаві спікери які будуть
залучені які вже залучені шкіл 50
країнах світу вона була двічі визнана
найкращою директором школи в Сполучених
Штатах Америки це шоломкові президент
компанії
і
альбока а епоха ви вже знаєте завтра до
речі він виступає від виступає в Києві
міжнародний експерт проекту навчаємося
разом до речі сьогодні він вже записує
записує свої лекції для школи
національної школи управлінських кадрів
у нас також є українські цікаві стікери
вони це теж декілька слів скажу А
можливо навіть їм дам по три секунд щоб
вони сказали
це учасники учасники національної школи
резерву управлінських кадрів ми просимо
вас по декілька слів сказати про вашу
програму щоб ми як керівники областей
розуміли що за програма що вона перед
особливо Зверніть увагу на стажування
[музика]
Скажіть будь ласка
Шановні колеги я хочу звернути увагу на
те що за останні десятиліття нарешті як
вони Міністерство освіти ви підняли
питання підготовки резерву управлінських
кадрів власне відновили те що було гарно
українське в світі
ній я думаю що всі практики вам за це
будуть щиро дякувати
оскільки це дуже потрібно справа ви
знаєте відомий український філософ Іван
дезюк писав про красу педагогічної дії А
ми хочемо показати наше майбутнє
директорам
показати
ілюзію кращих директорів і тому
недаремно ми акцентуємо увагу на
співпраці інститут модернізації змісту
освіти із департаментами із регіонами з
обласними
ми будемо просити вас працювати разом
сформувати команди кращих директорів
лідерів лідерів громадської думки
у разі яких будуть проходити стажування
майбутньої
директорів І власне На цьому наша є
система незавершується бо ми будемо
просити і долучати до нашої ідеї і
університети для того щоб
університети розробили спеції програми
підготовки резерву управлінських кадрів
як для галузі освіти та Іллінці з
галузей І власне вже на 5-6 курсах
обласних курса
х Вони готували молодий резерв для в
першу чергу для закладів освіти власне я
хочу подякувати ще раз
мій ініціативу і закликати всіх
присутних департаментів ректорів
обласний інституті до співпраці з
реалізації цієї важливої важливого
проекту оскільки
підготовка вчителів Це дуже добре
будь-які новації які його освіті завжди
починаються з педагогів це прекрасно але
допоки ми не сформуємо погоду сучасний
інноваційний директорів шкіл які стоять
на сторонах змін власне які самі
ініціюють зміни ми не досягнемо успіхи
без організації
інститут обдарованих дітей
щодо розвитку педагогічного і
продовження того що зазначити вживання
Наталя це дійсно дуже важлива програма
написано програму це нагальна потрібна і
Якщо говорити про безпосередньо за
даними функція який відповідає тобто
цінності можна говорити багато це і
дослідження це і експериментальна база
це такі методики які технології але в
будь-якому випадку цінності за секс сенс
будь-якої діяльності тому що цей
професійною і в даному урок ми
покладаємося на підсинерію викладаємо
інтеграцію з метою викладаємо менеджмент
практики сучасних українських і тому
буде результат а результатом є вчитель
професійний вчитель який викладував свою
власну систему
психологічна може і бути носіями і
навчати рішення
Дякую пане Артуру і Антону цю Антон Цюпа
будь ласка фотосинних ініціатив доброго
очевидно що впровадження освітніх
іноманців загалом і система освіти
зокрема потребує в закладі освіти
управлінської роботи організаційної
роботи на сьогоднішній день Сьогодні ми
вже функція не хотіти вивчає кращі
практики які є в Україні крім того нашим
партнером є незалежна організація яка
займається кандидатацією сертифікацією
системи вчителів та захисту штучних
Штатах Америки і видно ми можемо цими
матеріалами теж приділитися в рамках
школи управлінської системи
Шановні колеги Дуже дякую І
на завершення вам маленький анонс це
четвертий компонент про який я анонсував
на початку
але якщо є у вас питання що робити з
утриманням школи коли 80 коли школа
з'їдає 80% бюджету територіальної
громади що робити коли видатки на учнів
понад 40-5 тисяч гривень були в
середньому 25 що робити коли один
викладач читає 3-5 предметів і нам
глядача менше 10 учнів Я думаю що
набагато цих питань багатьох відповідь
чи школу таку треба оптимізувати і дітей
весь обробну школу і так далі але є і
альтернативне інша думка є інноваційний
проект братів ви сьогодні вперше почуєте
він буде про нього буде наш партнера
атмосферна школа доповідати На другій
частині Дякую за увагу
[оплески]
Шановні колеги Ми продовжуємо Нашу З
вами презентаційну платформу грошу спів
доповідачів міністра освіти трішечки
вживатися в час тому що час
регламентовано ми тепер не можемо піти з
вами на карту тому що продовжуємо
слухати наших колег інші інститути до
слова Я запрошую директора інституту
розвитку освіти Вадима карандія будь
ласка
Доброго дня шановні колеги Я постараюся
зняти мінімум часу тому що говорити про
те речі які ви вже знаєте а розкриють
деякі особливості ну по-перше у мене
невеличка інституція нас лише три
десятки але наша головна задача - це
буде тим хто вирішує питання подолання
наслідків континентів
створення цифрового середовища
організація змішаного навчання також
розвиток відповідних навичок та
компетентностей як у педагогів так і в
наших дітей учнів навіть все зафіксовано
як освітніх так і у
професійних стандартах Наразі я допоможу
про всеукраїнську школу онлайн
[музика]
Це продукт який з'явився буквально
останні року виклик на ті відповіді які
існували в основну увагу яку ми
приділяли це якості матеріалу і
створюються оскільки це фактично вперше
загальнонаціональна система
і матеріали які можливості органі
зувати воно засновано на лікарне
навчання воно містить відповідні якісні
навчальні відео конспекти для
додаткового опрацювання завдань для
садових перевірки а також для екскурсії
але увагу потрібно робити над кабінету
вчителя який є в кожному курсі який дає
можливість чи треба спланувати свої
власні класи і працювати із своїми
дитячими
також всім кабінетах є можливість
створювати відповідно у власність До
речі маю сказати що на сьогоднішній день
таких курсів вже завантажено вчителями
Близько трьох тисяч
[музика]
всього на сьогодні ми маємо 200 тисяч
користувачів із них 150 учнів і вчителів
40000 ми бачимо впевненість пропорцією
вчителів їх більше 50 тенденція
зберігається впродовж е-е всього року це
зумовлено рядом причин і одна із їх те
що не всі вчителі запрошують свої учнів
і ми вірити вчителі які потребують
відповідної підтримки і допомоги ви
плануванні навички для того щоб можна
було користуватися спортивними системами
повсякденно тому що я ще раз говорю це
не лише система дистанційного навчання А
це система для змішаного навчання
Але є одна новація яка фактично Зараз ми
можемо вже про неї говорити цю роботу ми
розпочали ще якісь в березні місяці
колись з'явилася постанова Кабінету
Міністрів якої було визначено що
відповідно платформа всеукраїнська школа
онлайн є складової глобальної платформі
дія цифрова освіта і
адміністраторм якої є 20 центральних
органів виконавчої влади це Міністерство
освіти і науки України які відповідають
за змістом організації роботи і за
технічну підтримку розвиток відповідної
платформи
цифрової трансформації
маємо повідомити про те що в жовтні
місяці видано наказ Міністерства освіти
він уже зі сторони це порядок наповнення
платформи вишивок освітні матеріали і
саме в цей порядок ми складали всі оті
основні
нюанси щодо синергії інтеграції та
співпраці ця Справа в тому що на
сьогодні творценції платформи контенту
може бути не лише Міністерство його
підбірну чи структури зокрема у євро як
адміністратора контенту А може бути
будь-хто із вас взагалі будемо говорити
із експертного сере
довища створюйте відповідні матеріали
для того
приєрозкою на сьогодні експертну Раду до
неї пішло років коло фахівців в тому
числі і представники академії
педагогічних наук які визначають
доцільних тис та інших курсів також
визначають які експертизи ці кур пройти
для того щоб отримати своє місце на
відповідній платформі
тож усіх вас Якщо є відповідні курси які
заслуговують уваги і які можуть бути
представлені на цій платформі звертатися
особливостя Ще раз підкреслюю Це повинен
бути якісний матеріал він повинен бути
безкоштовний для кінцевого користувача
який його використовує але всі авторські
права в тому числі якого тих хто його
створював Ці курси при розміщенні на
платформі будуть збережені
які ж порядок дій ну Перше потрібно
розуміти що той хто ініціює перед нашою
відповідного курсу має свою до
адміністратора центру української
інституту
розвитку експертна Рада має Визначити
види необхідної експертизи також
повідомити таких експертів установок
такі експертизи фахові можуть бути е-е
якщо будуть відповідні позитивні
висновки адміністратор забезпечить
розміщення відповідних курсів на
всеукраїнській
платі онлайн
які перспективи Що ми плануємо зараз
значить крім того що ми маємо завершити
ті курси які на сьогодні є ви знаєте що
їх 73 ми
до тих
2008 році додамо ще 39
3 умови та математики алгебра геометрія
сьомий 11-й клас
крім того наступного рік ми плануємо що
маємо покрити повністю всі курси 35-6
класу тому що вони вже під по новому
стандарту
матеріалів для
того щоб можливо увага на сьогодні ми
приділяємо
початковій школі тому що існує дуже
великий запит дуже багато звернених на
те що ми дали можливість і початковій
школі організувати змішувати навчання в
такому разі ми на сьогодні все під
керівників і серед країною напрацювали
концеп
цію Знайомтесь на сайті уірог або ось
тут на виставці суть полягає в тому що
більше фокусація буде відбуватися на
іграх та як реалізації процесів особливі
інтерфейсі зокрема в тому числі на
смартфона це залученість батьків і
багато взаємодії та різних системних
логічно
наступна перспектива яку ми вбачаємо і
ми до того прагнемо це курси для
вчителів вся Справа в тому що на
сьогодні дуже багато матеріалів
від проблематики про обласного
комфортного шо існує в Україні які
готувалися за донорські підтримки
різноманітних організацій вони розміщені
на різні платформі Прометеус ентери та
інших багатьох випадках термін підтримки
їхній впливає тому ми ініціюємо міграцію
всіх відповідних курсів на платформу
вашого з єдиною точкою входу для
користувачів потенційних вчителів Чи
дасть можливість режисером представити
ті матеріали які на сьогодні вже
напрацьовані і можуть бути безкоштовних
використовуватися
вчителем це до речі дуже непогана буде
база матеріальна безпосередників
закладів післядипломної освіти для того
щоб розвивати тиждень формати роботи маю
сказати Що наприклад за сьогодні ми вже
маємо таку
пропозицію проекту навчання це фізичні
проектів які всі ті курс які
за трьох років уже відповідно листом
асоціюють передачу для розміщення на
всеукраїнськ на платформі всеукраїнська
школа онлайн Також ми свідків проектом
на сьогодні опрацьовуємо питання щодо
створення системи відзнак рівня цифрової
компетентності Можливо ви чули це
система вежі коли наприклад
професійну компетентність або взагалі
професійний стандарт для вчителя можна
не розписуватись такими географічними
базами а підставити у вигляді з гачків і
фактично Вчитель буде розвиватися
рухатись по цьому корупційному стандарту
шляхом набору відповідних військ
власників вчителів це створення
неможливо коли ми не будемо мати
маленьких нам частину
всіх я маю сказати про інших проекти які
на сьогодні ми робимо теж відробиться
впродовж останнього року це проект уроку
це проект спільно із
юнісеком зокрема у героями робити А
взагалі це глобальний проект і серпня
просто яким представлені університети
які дає можливість Зібрати всі
онлайн-ресурси які є безкоштовні для
відповідних національних систем
[музика]
якщо бачите вони всі україномовні Це або
наша українська розробка або дуже гарна
адаптація світових
і є у нас відкриті
проект наразі запрошую до свого пан
ді всі авторів
всесвітньої кваліфікації будь ласка тому
що презентація вже почалася
Доброго дня
вчителіну Сьогодні працюють доволі такі
багатоманітний шкільний колективах в
класах жительство залучати до навчання з
таких різних учнів
комунальних чи будь-які форми
дискримінації і
задовольняють право на освіту кожного
учня чи учениці
таким інструментом є мкф або в
українській інтерпретації яку його зараз
будемо представляти це мкф для
інклюзивної освіти зараз
змінити оточення чи рустами а не сама
дитина спостерігаючи за дитиною в класі
уважний вчитель може з'ясувати що саме
створює труднощі для діяльності від
пропонує зручний
для визначення особливостей такої
Вона може допомогти вчителю вести у
клітинність спостереження за діяльністю
людини виявляти носове перешкоди та
створювати дружній освітнє середовище
енергійну участь для цього медичного
діагнозом крім того МКС Та є можливість
вчителю позначити позиціант і синус 41
Отож міжнародний класифікація
функціонування це той інструменти який
дійсно скаже нам про те що з них
потребує уточнення а не дитина і за
допомогою цього інструменту якось щойно
побачили вчительця і може якісно
спостерігати за участю і діяльність у
кожної дитини в умовах інклюзивного
навчання не тільки мовами інклюзивного
навчання для того щоб створити дружнє
якісне освітнє середовище і при цьому
нукруватися медичними
Варто сказати про те що цей інструмент
розроблений всесвітньої організації
охорони здоров'я втім його контекст є
значно ширший і Він вимагає на сьогодні
до нас стати єдиною такою умовою різних
сферах у тому числі і в освітній сфері
соціальній сфері і медичній сфері також
А щодо запровадження в Україні
міжнародної класифікації функціонування
обмежень життєдіяльності та здоров'я ну
власне коротко я кажу мкр та її
інтегрування систем освіти то це є
беззаперечний Фактор А варто пригадати
про те що Україна є підписантом
Конвенції про права осіб з інвалідністю
2009 року а це значно змінює вектор а з
позиції з інвалідності коли ми дивимося
на дитину і на середовища варто
виглядати закон України про освіту де
йдеться про інклюзивне навчання як
систему послуг про освіту з особливими
освітніми потребами Як таких що
потребують підтримки
постійної частини тобто особою
особливого освітніми потребами в
будь-який період свого життя може бути
будь-яка дитина і звичайно це
національна Стратегія і створення
безбар'єрного простору в Україні на
період до 2030 року тому що саме
ці національні стратегії йдеться про те
що мкф має бути тільки телеканал системи
освіти
докладніше про те чому на часі МКС що
таке мпл Я не буду зупинятися бо про це
можуть дізнатися з наших буклетів Вони є
на першому поверсі біля літератури а
також ці всі матеріали можна завантажити
вони є теж у вільному доступі
а зупинюся власне вже безпосередньо на
самій юнісен Україні у квартирі з
громадської організації
соціально-синелія за участі уєру та
безпосередньо підтримки Міністерства
освіти науки України а що це за
платформа а на ній міститься матеріали
просвітницького змісту це різні
документи дослідження аналітика
анімаційні відео власне все те що
стосується
теми люди доступності і без бар’є
досягнення цієї платформи Це те що на
ній розміщений браузер міжнародної
класифікації функціонування що дає
можливість ознайомити користувачів зі
структурою та власне
І власне щодо статистики почав наша
платформа є доволі такою молодою Вона
працює
державного основного інституту освітньої
аналітики Ми займаємося
інформаційно-аналітичним забезпеченням
діяльності Міністерства ці індикатори
повинні забезпечити виявлення грибів з
таких
дискусій із практичними працівниками
Міністерства освіти і науки України
освітніх управління в результаті ми
маємо 22 базових таких показники які в
Стороні по 5
таких модулів
модулі ті або інформаційні блоки є такі
це здобувачі освіти педагогічні
працівники на третій пункт створення
сучасного освітнього середовища фінанси
освіти
на Росії
основні індикатори ми можемо отримати з
тих певних які ми збираємо тобто в нас є
форми статистичної звітності - це
державні форми затверджені ребер штатом
і деякі показники не вистачає вони
звернули Міністерство освіти науки
звернулося з листом того на ці місця
найбільші найбільшу увагу тому що вона
якби потребує до себе до себе уваги і
певних дій
але от є такого матриця для цього
індикатора Ну якщо подивитися на от оці
показники то найбільш такими
проблемами місцями є от
кількість закладів загальної середньої
освіти які не мають внутрішніх вбиралень
можливо це індикатор є тимчасовий але
поки що проблеми у нас є Ми з дані
представили на початок
2021 року от вона є 14,2 це є індикатор
який стосується підключення до мережі
Інтернет зі швидкістю більше 100 мг
і на землі
зарплати в розрізі регіонів оці чорні
стовпчики зверху це є склад місцевих
бюджетів за рахунок власності коштів як
бачимо
областях по-різному місцеві бюджети
вкладають
кошти додатково до освітньої коштів
освітньої субвенції знизу Це голубиці
коштує освітньої субвенції ну найбільше
вкладає кілька так що Дякую бабусю
викладачі за те що це робиться
наступне а це є обсяг залишків коштів
освітньої субвенції на початок потужного
року Ну також розхід є достатньо великий
і якщо наступний сад наступний справа
Тут є також теплова матриця для
зроблено Для цього цієї частини видно що
тих джерело тих місцях треба очевидно
здобути менеджером увагу і більше 100
працювати наступне є також інклюзія
наступний слайд також для цих показників
оброблено інформація і представлена у
вигляді теплової
матриця дітей з освітніми особливими
потребами які навчаються в інклюзивних
групах закладів дошкільної освіти Ну тут
є проблема є також в останньому правому
країни
це час закладів загальної середньої
освіти з архітектурною доступністю учнів
ліфти підйомників ну це загальна
українська проблема І тут дійсно треба
працювати І на весілля для того щоб ці
питання розширення і вот тут є матриця з
цих доступних індикатор на сьогодні яка
стосується
обставина освітлення ну
вода чим приваблювала тим що
був тут використано ризиком орієнтований
підхід він використовується зокрема
фінанса і менеджери головний погляд ми
можемо оцінити те є місця куди найбільше
треба сухоживати свою увагу для того щоб
пізніше направити свої зусилля і
поправити ситуацію далі
Ну таким чином
при створенні якщо людина використаний
ризику орієнтований підхід
дані які ці дев'ятої які сформувалися
вони можуть дає змогу менеджера побачити
такі ж проблемні місця в розвитку освіти
і для це для того щоб спрямувати зусилля
передусім де їх по
долання Ну і сподіваємося що
ліпінського стане корисним інструментом
для освітніх управлінців у процесі
опалення виважених Отже також додати що
такі ж самі
тепловілатриці можуть бути збудовані на
для кожної області в розрізі е-е
територіальних громад сільських селищних
міських і також для скажемо в цьому разі
можна буде побачити ті місця куди в
першу чергу відповідав всіх індикаторів
необхідно покосилати свої увагу які дії
треба робити Дякую за увагу а я ще Також
хотів анонсувати в нас є адреса
в нас є ще друга якби частина
інноваційних
яка стосується інноваційного провадження
інституту аналітики в першу чергу це
стосується
[музика]
впровадження індивідуальної та
професіоналізованої інформації
дошкільної шкільної а в цьому році це ще
й буде позашкілля а в наступному
очікуємо
професійною освітою то один із основних
інструментів які системи економ з
технічними адміністрування даної системи
але її системою
автоматизації роботи інклюзивного
ресурсних центрів і яка постійно
розвивається з кожним роком набирає нову
функціоналу Ми також забезпечуємо
співпрацю з центрами оцінювання якості
освіти з інститутами модернізації змісту
освіти прозорий вибір та замовлення
підручників для захисту всієї системи
загальної середньої освіти також на
основі наших даних здійснюється
практично кожен розподіл який
має На порядку денному Міністерстві
освіти Ми моделюємо освітнє субвенцію ми
легко набори ми в численні інші програма
наприклад на кшталт ноутбук кожного
вчителю тощо тощо покращує інтернет і
так далі Тому це до чого підложу
художник до того що гарна якість даних
це автоматично гарний розподіл тому не
дно тяжко перецінити важливість
ретельности в наповненості в наповненні
системи національної
оцих освітніх показників освітніх даних
Так я розумію тепер кранів капітан
доповідати буквально два слова система
сертифікованого процедурі
атестації комплексної системи захисту
інформації
про здобувші освіти педагогічним
працівників і відповідний збір не
потребує
повторююсь з поєднався збір згод про
обробку персональних даних І скільки ми
збираємо відповідну інформацію на
реалізацію конституційного права дитини
на освіту та в рамках повноважень
центрального органу виконавчої влади по
його потребами
Якщо говорити про такі модулі альбома
які ще є на слуху і в активному розвитку
то варто згадати
державні безкоштовні електронні
щоденники та журнали які не тільки
розвиваються але й розвиваються в
контенті в якості інтерфейсу але які в
підключення сторонніх альтернативних
програмних продуктів яких е-е зрозуміло
що вони є домінуючі У нас сьогодні на
ринку освітніх послуг і ми плануємо що
найближче півроку ми охопимо 2/3 заклади
загальної середньої освіти за рахунок
підключення альтернативних програмах
продуктів Також
ця функціоналу знайома є сьогодні
конструктор форм у світі і засоби
візуалізації та збори піані і протоколи
взаємодії і можливість проведення
будь-яких опитувань чи багато з яких
було гроно саме в період тоді перших
місяців роботи в умовах пандемії
вимагати з пенсійки бо треба було
проводити замір тих чи інших показників
оперативного і на сьогодні далі
ще далі
і це пропустим далі
ми маємо також такі речі як
На порядку як побудова взаємодія через
Трембіту через шину обміня з
національними реєстрами коли ми не
будемо вимушені вносити якісь показники
коли вони вже існують на національному
рівні Також ми будемо кваліфікувати
інформацію в автоматичному режимі при
внесенні її при заповнений Ми
також
розуміємо що
ми маємо
збалансувати ту потребу і завдання які
стануть на Міністерство як замовник тих
чи інших функціональних і з тими
візіями які є на рівні користувачів
закладів освіти на рівні випуски
місцевих управління освітою тому ми є
завжди в діалозі завжди
продукт кращий якісніше далі І так
останній слайд уже перед тим як я
подякую Я вважаю що якщо робити
повноваженням кроку то можна прийти до
великого результату якщо щось
забувати кожного дня то потім нас чекає
якась прірва тому Я закликаю всіх хто
Контакту для того щоб ми
перемогли ці якісь недоопрацювання які є
сьогодні спільно і розвинули нашу
систему управління освітою тобто до
нього якісного рівня я Всім дякую тоді
якщо якісь питання
[оплески]
запрошую президента Національної
академії педагогічних наук Василя кре
менева
конференцію
6:45
[музика]
і
я бачу по суті будуть трішки
перебудували
що ми можемо якось констатуватись що
разом з вами
розпочали створити нову українську школу
30 років назад коли
українські держави і калина в місті
[музика]
впровадження про шкільного автобуса 2018
річна структура української школи що
відповідають світовим стандартам тривало
судової середньої середньої освіти Я б
сказав не те що що відповідає а що
відповідає мінімальним стандартам
Сьогодні
знову ж таки тут я хотів би щоб
виокремити завдання профільного навчання
Старша пазова школа і на мій погляд Ви
повинні настільки це підприємство що за
рік прийняття школи громад
ського це вже ліцей на підготовку
академічний
це професійна рухоми Чи це впало воно
значить все це
якась
те що ми називаємо профільною школи тому
що окрім інших скажімо
завдання функції і коледжу 32-й
рік хлопців
старшої школи
підвищення автономії закладів освіти
наступних принципів з метою врахування
освітніх потреб звітності країн рейсів з
виборчих осіб я добавив що із підвищення
автономії закладу і з урахуванням
конкретних особливостей діяльності цього
закладу
Чернігівщині
звичайно
великі ліси
[музика]
десь у місті Києві 103 і тут потрібно
надати основну нам більше більшу
статуновних заклада
ми далі наступний принцип професійних
зростання і вдосконалення вчителів
математичній Свободи можливості для
виявлення того
часу як колись коли був міністром
виграв розпорядження заборонити
біографію дальність про оцінки дітей у
школі заборонити справді сусідками які
виставляючи вчительці учнів і оцінка -
це це відносно від між собою якщо ми
скажімо зверху
насаджуємо необхідність
регулярної формування про ці російські
так то безумовно вчитель Який вчитель
сьогодні
свідомістю десь орієнтуватися на те що
йому потрібно відповідальність перед
директором школи а директора школи більш
висо
якомога реалізації цінностей сучасного
суспільства та забезпечення якісною
як вона називається
[музика]
не тільки на те що я сказав за великим
рахунком якщо ми готуємо подих
педагогіку партнерства
ми будемо в наших майбутні демократичних
суспільстві демократичні країни по
демократія не там лише там де
демократичні президент буде
парламент хоча це потрібно без
замовлення демократія там де є критична
маса громадян даної країни які здатні
життю демократії і не здатні життю
автократії або тим більше еротикального
суспільства і здатність чи не здатність
до демократії формується на шкільній
план якщо людина дитина 10-12 років
авторитарному впливі вчителя при нашому
до себе організації дорослої буде
вимагати відсві
і таким чином ми нікому не допомагати
демократичне суспільство якщо не
перекладує грошей Надія слові нашого
світу а-а ведемократичну суспільство це
вже завжди більше ніж
Перемоги Шановні колеги я хотів би
сказати що
Для загальної середньої освіти
Національної академії Бердичів наук
розвитку
багато як міг би згадати дуже гарну
практику на мій погляд я згадав би
сьогодні Платона ми на початку 2000-х
років була підписана підписана угода
Міністерства Національної академії
Національної академії підвищення
правопису підпис особового пересінини
е-е про підготовку державних стандартів
зараз асистенти були першої державної
стандартом 99-й - 2004 роки потім було
пам'ятаєте друге покоління стандартів
2011 року зараз новий період
стандартизації змісту освіти як ви
знаєте затверджений третє покоління
державного стандарту початкової освіти в
20-му році затверджений державний
стандартним середньої освіти які тоді
вже на цю ситуацію а їх Нагадай себе 20
чого немає ніде абсолютно
Я знаю як це буде складно але ми повинні
жостко різне обмеженості
обов'язково предметів профільного
навчання інакше ми не наші перебудови в
мережі цих органів ліцеї і ліцеї і
інші Якщо у нас буде Вибачте та гармошка
яку ми маємо сьогодні залишили у
старшій школі з догляду кількості
предметів
безумовно першочергова роль в новій
українській школі належить початкових
осіб Шановні колеги Якби я ж не заважав
початкової освіти яка власне закладає в
основі і грамотності всього іншого
ви знаєте що по чотири освіти є буде дві
освітні програми Нам дуже приємно що
одна із освітніх програм яка була
розроблена в академії керівництвами
навчання методичним забезпеченням з усіх
предметів
вимірюємо матеріали і таке інше
всеукраїнської інформаційного проекту
технології навчання
[музика]
спільно з виробникам розроблений
впровадження технологій формування
навчального середовища на щитової школи
на основі електронних ігрових реченні
ресурсів і всі 10% вчителів бойового
використання
організовано що впродовж кількох років
новонароджених регулярно роботу постійно
є чіткі що семінар знаходиться і
технології початкового навчання
організації і скажемо наступних
працівників передбачає на педагогів
інших технологій більшістю
Запрошуємо вас використати сьогодні
І на завершення є ще хочу сказати про
наступне
з нами започатковано успішна дія вже 10
років але але ми хочемо дійсно поблизу
на всіх мендерів депутатській 10 хвилин
е-е представити результати дослідження
яке озвучує сьогодні і міністр і
збудували наших інститутів це питання
здоров'я Так ось питання створення
безпечного освітнього середовища а саме
подолання кубингу розкриває Людмила
Марченко депутат України яка поводилась
поділитись скласти досить а будь ласка
[музика]
Доброго дня шановні колеги
Людмила Марченко народний депутат
України Тернопільщина Дякую що сьогодні
Всі зібрались Але сьогодні я тут ніяк не
робить депута
Т рука Як іде на лідер дуже важливого
проекту який називається пружний простір
це проект який стосується
можливого питання про сьогодні стоїть на
порядку даному він у Верховній Раді від
установлений університет запитання про
створення власне якщо дозволити пару
слів скажу досить особисто нещодавно
прийшовши додому мало розмову зі своїм
сином і він мені повідомив про дуже
такий складний Фактор у житті шкільного
про те що відбулося в класі дуже негарна
ситуація де дівчина однокласниця якщо
можна так популярним це кажуть правила
хлопця однокласника виконавчої нагороду
навчально-пій знущаючись в нього це все
знімалося на відео телефоном мобільного
про що побачили ми батьки насправді були
дуже здорово
коли зацікавилася питання власне що
відбувається звернулась до директора
почала відповідь А в нас
[музика]
знаєте насправді ця ситуація я маючи
таку посаду будучи списочним депутатом
дозволяючи фракцію президента сьогодні
маємо можливість і дякую відповідно
керівникам з міністерства які нас почули
і ми були здивовані що ці люди роблять
роблять роблять але Ми зрозуміли що
система не працює Тому що вони внизу що
я зі своїми палатками своїми помічника
всім нам з вами дав шанс Господь
народився але не точно буде жити по
смерті дуже часто Перепрошую Я би дуже
хотіла щоб ми з вами всі Дружба наших
дітей ті що і наділи що вони ростуть на
наших учасників точно не займалися цього
речам тому сьогодні треба акумулювати
енергію акумулювати знання і працювати
створення електронного онлайн-ресу
інструментами будь ласка
що це таке Це фактично програмне
забезпечення яке в принципі є
дорогуватись але ми вже сьогодні знайшли
кошти для розробки програмного
забезпечення Дякую чи альбому вони нам
сьогодні дозволили розміститися в себе
на ресурсі для того щоб зібратися
статистику для вас це дуже потрібно
статистика яку ви зможете оперувати в
майбутньому створюючи різноманітні
підзаконні акти Чи ті самі люди чи
документи які дозволять Вам сьогодні
змінити програму навчання в школах там
ви зможете і авторизувати Дані ви
зможете її моніторити цю дитинку коли
діти не хочуть повідомляти про свої дані
тому і той і той варіант підходить у
випадку якщо дитина записує свої дані
відкритим шляхом повідомляє про своє
ім'я ці дані корпусу на ці дані отримує
зразу декілька різних підрозділів
починаючи Міністерства закінчуючи
психологом збільшуючи працівниками якщо
власна дитина не зазначила своїх даних
офіційно інформації іде на гарячу лінію
ресурсу де починає працювати психолог
який в принципі зможуть зв'язатися
оскільки з ная вність номер телефону є
обов'язковим в цій програмі шоу
зв'язується з дитиною починає працювати
витягувати дитину на розмову для того
щоб така дитина сама повідомити вам дана
Що відбулося В школі
кабінет директора саме в цьому кабінеті
директор буде бачити абсолютно всю
інформацію статистичну в його школі що
відбувається зможу порівняти свої дані
зі школами які знаходяться біля нього в
його регіоні в цілому цілою України
власне в розрізі з цілої України може
побачити в динаміці на графіках любив
зручним способом Справа в тому що
сьогодні чомусь тракторист тримають
булінг як хворобу І коли ти питаєш
Скажіть будь ласка яка ситуація на школі
ви кажете в нас нема На все добре таким
відчуття що взяти от дуже напевно важко
або складно признатися що звичайно в нас
це є ми були проїздили з вами колегами
школи ми побачили що дійсно нема А я вже
цифра чому ж вона росте Тобто діти
заявляєте в кампашночки а в школі даних
нема Значить ми відносяться не можна
сказати коли давайте нас вчимося
спочатку проявляти проблему і про неї
говорити Я дуже дякую нашому президенту
за цю річ всі речі які він зробив для
нас він почав говорити про рекламу і ми
сьогодні маємо десь через пару років Ми
почнемо відверто казати що в нас є
позитивна динаміка доручення чи наші
діти стали більш лояльніші тертими що і
розуміємо щодо розуміння що таке
конфлікти комунікації в нічну
відпрацьовувати ці навички вміння
швидкого якісного виходу звітної
ситуації
Ось так виглядає лист якщо можна його
назвати фактично роботу директора якщо
власне до нього поступають дані що
відбулася ситуація яка зв'язана з
булінгу директор має абсолютно чіткий
шаблон ті що має зробити крок один крок
2 поетапний керуючись нормативними
документами що є нормальний шлях виходу
ситуації не бійка для цього потрібно
пропонувати навчати наших дітей наступне
сайт діти розуміли знову таки що тут
слід і це не треба це просто якщо сісти
в автомобіль і рівно 21 день
присьохуватися правда то на 22 прийдеш в
офіс і автоматично будеш на кріслі
шукати ремонт безпеки де би то
присягнутися
точно організм сформуватись з дітьми те
саме ситуація була клас розуміння що це
проблема хто вийти в свій період у нас
вже доєдналися таке розуміння кіборг
це ще страшніше а одразу після змаганнях
речей
свідомі ось тут Що залежить Все від нас
Якщо ви не вибито далі будь ласка
задавайте дякую
Дякую
благодійного фонду освіти ініціатив який
поділився інформація про мережу з цим
центрів як сервісна модель реформи нової
української школи будь ласка
Доброго дня
Дякую за можливість виступити Якщо
коротко
насправді концепція нової української
школи вона базується на кращих світових
правилах насправді його на сцену
зорієнтовано тому що у світі концепція
stem-освітиться нова школа
нова школа - це новий вчительку
тому що ж таке Stem і як він нам
допомагає далі реформувати руку
що необхідно але успішному
меню системними проектування
міжпредметні наукові математичні та
цифрові
компете це вже зароджуються в середовищі
stem-освіти стенд це підготовлені
педагогів та технологічні лабораторії
- Це статифіковане обладнання комплектів
фото та відеостудії було графічними
проєкціями лазерні камери та світові
фрезери команда темп педагогів - це
потужна енергія якістьної освіти ними
стають після спеціального навчання
суперлізій та методо
затримання навчальних матеріалів та
програм
стенд - це сьогодення сучасної освіти
нова українська школа говорить про
інформатичну освіту ось автори
інформатичного освітньої галузі
державного стандарту освіти Оксана
Пасічник Людмила Черникова вони
звертають увагу що нова українська школа
формує творців ми переходимо маємо
перейти від суспільства споживання до
суспільно-творення інструментами є в
тому числі і stem-освіта
разом з цифровим громадянством
формування обчислювальному цифрових
компетентності якщо просто подивитися на
концепцію нової української школи
побачити ті ключі від компетентності які
у нас записані в законі України про
освіту Ми можемо так скажімо закриваючи
дорогу подивитися Та тут же є
стенд-компетентності але насправді От
наприклад спілкування іноземними мовами
теж формується в системі системи освіти
от для мене наприклад виявилось цікава
для того що країни для яких англійська
мова не є рідною вони з цим центри
відкривають такі які працюють
англійською мовою
і коли ми спілкувалися з одною з таких
країн вони вперше запитали Якою мовою
спілкуються з тим освітом України
відповім зручно українською автоматично
але потім задумався що напевно
в тому числі це цікава думка і напевно
правду якщо ми говоримо про проектну
діяльність служби
формування центру патентності то Звісно
що екологічно-екологічна грамотність теж
формується
ініціативність І підприємливість
наприклад
Сьогодні стартапенко який є вони бачать
проблему
яка у серед тих учнів серед тих
студентів які відкривають свої перші
стартапи намагаються це робити вони
бачать потребу поглибленої додаткового
підприємства фінансо у світі починаючи
зі школи і це теж Можливо в системі Stem
стоїть і Звісно що спілкування державної
мови соціально громадянська
компетентності
це фактично ті компетентності
і система освіти Ми сьогодні ми маємо
концепцію розвитку stem-освіти в Україні
план заходів які ми передбачено
відкриття подальшому відкриття
землеботорії і сен-центорів але чим
більше починаємо працювати тим більше
виникає Скажімо так зона знання і
виникає питання викликів ось наприклад
далі в національні економічні стратегії
на період життя того року ми через одну
з цільових антикаторів бачимо а-а
досягнення рівня 80% система освіти в
закладах загальної середньої освіти
такі цілі потребують звісно зміни
освітнього середовища у нас є 5
70 єдине що питання яке першочергово на
якому етапі ну загалом всі дослідження
світового
говорять про те що сьогодні учні вроді
треба давати мікроконтролери А загалом
зустріну освіта починається з Учителя з
тренінгів з методичних матеріалів як
показують досвід каналу і Сполучених
Штатів Америки оцінок прокурору
щоб вони починали усі з Учителя
наприклад є програма Канада 2067 про
перехід повністю на тему освіти вона
говорить про те що всі школи мають
змінитися і перше що починає Канада вони
дають можливість раз на кожного вчителя
обійти підвищення ква
ліфікації в частині тематиці в програмах
які стосуються з теми також це НАТО
утворює
динамічні професійні навчальні спільноти
система освіти - це
колектив вчителів в школі система освіта
це спілкування шкільних колективів
між і також Звісно що необхідні
навчальні методики що там на 90% попадає
в шлях Канади Я не знаю яким чином це
сталося але це книга про
майбутнє все змінює Всю школу тому що
Stem змінює вчителя і це сьогодні
Можливо на сьогодні є вже погано
позитивні кейси в Україні а коли
педагогічний колектив починає по-іншому
працювати І це не окремі кабінет який у
школі чи по всьому світі всі якісна
освіта гідна праця економічне зростання
та системи освіти впливає на цю
глобальну цілі і так система освіти
впливає на досягнення на створення
якісної промисловості інноваційних
інфраструктури ці групи цілі важливі для
всієї України але на жаль цього
зовнішньої агресією вони категорично
важливі сьогодні для Донецької
які Скажімо так зробили в тому числі
свою домашню роботу Пішли трошки вперед
і
відкривають спільну з міжнародними
партнерами з програми розвитку в Україні
центр як він має працювати як я не маю
утворюватися який продукт має давати в
подальшому
з цим центром має бути частиною
регіональних напів освітніх хай-тек до
бачення ось таке це і освітні фаблапи
які працюють на базі з цим центром
спільно з ними так з цим центр скільки
ця робота з учителями має розвивати
школи і в них розвивати мають працювати
систем прокураторії
Звісно ж це все є інвестиції
стартапенко-інкубатори це теж не
досліджує воно все обертається назад і
сьогодні є можливість налагоджувати ці
інформаційні освітні зв'язки між
системою економіки стартапенко Ватра
бізнеса акселераторами і
загалом закладами розуміння Отже сам
центрі у нас є проблеми ми бачимо уже
частина Скажімо так нової української
школи впроваджено і ми бачимо що
батьки не Всі розуміють що відбувається
ми побачили це про це говорив Міністр
освіти ми бачимо всі дослідження
фактично така структура як
стан центру вони могли би виконувати
функції діалогу з громадськістю
популяризуючих питань реформи системи
освіти
діалог на Майдані це через реальну
роботу через регенерацію та гармонізацію
тимчасового переміщених осіб то там з
оператором буду у служби зайнятості
через підготовку фахівців професії
найближчого майбутнього простим центр
має бути двері мають бути відкриті у
відстані Для постійних хто в центрі
громад і шалену підтримку подальших
реформ у систему освіти і звісно Вони
мають працювати з вчителями із
керівниками закладів освіти і звісно
Вони мають працювати з модом додавати
можливість
подальшого розвитку
молоді учнів отакий отважнення це
бачення вкладу стикається зараз на
озвучастому спільну міністерству освіти
з інститутом модернізації змісту освіти
експеримент
сподіваюся що всі області всі партнери
місто Київ Русі чи до чого експерименту
в нього можуть увійти як заклади
загальної середньої освіти як споживачів
цих послуг на профтехітів
професійно-технічного світу так і
обласні інститути підвищення
кваліфікації які можуть на своїй базі
відкривати такий темп центри Дякую за
увагу Дякую
дуже захоплення номер цікаві пропозиції
і продовження нашої розмови запрошую
очільника освітньої
організації як інструмент сучасної
освіти
міста Києва хочу вам розповісти про
відносини такі продукти які ми зараз
впровадженим
історичних дій це проект як називається
буквар тобто як складові рух книга і
клас яка абревіатура спеціальності
додаток віртуальної реальності і додаток
що ж насамперед що таке доповнена така
реальність
- це в принципі в світі який створений
штучний який створений засобами
комп'ютерно
рної в нього як можна отримати Так що я
потрапити таких писаннях що вони
реальності або ж популярне питання
накидає він
охороні
програмістів
чому його
[музика]
якась Що наприклад
деталя
цивілізованості проект краще відносно
ніж 100%. якщо учні розповідати про
про піраміди
можна показати малюнки але якщо жінок
це набагато буде
більше учнів будуть розповідати так як
він сам себе бачу як це все максимально
реалістично
стосується закону
це також декілька об'єкти які створені
але яких можна побачити за допомогою
телефонів
Наприклад якщо ми
зараз також показати
ці пам'ятки
України
історичні події
як ми орієнтували це
в нашому випадку
Віртуальна реальність ми зробили з
уроків фізики з 8 роботи 10 клас у
кожному класі по 40 дослідження коли
учні натягає на себе питання він
опиняється в
фізики але ми його зробили вже не як
класична фізики А як е-е учасник
значить він може продемонтувати якщо
його приміщення дозволиться або
поставити обмеження що якщо це робити на
місці можливо той інші варіанти
оскільки вони можуть відповідати
національним образом і мати То тільки
все інше але звісно
але вони будуть на калькулятор для того
щоб поступити до астронату можна
запустити
на великому екрані який знаходиться в
цьому кабінеті
експериментів обравши експеримент
наприклад
внутрішнього згорання парку українська
робота
на сторінці з'явиться весь такий
інвентар
і почнеться робити з того що умови
закатом почне розповідати призначення
кожного складових цього
навчання для чого
для того щоб провести експеримент дитина
сама
виникає або вмикає балів
якщо прокоментують проточний експеримент
який можна аналогічний тому що робиться
в класі питання
те що не проводили сюди
наприклад всі знають що
будуть не можна якщо ви зробите це
віртуальному кабінеті то побачите
питання більше
дає можливість
[музика]
обладнання пройти досвід кожного разу
наприклад повторити
досить і подивіться що правильно Він
зробив цей дослід
що стосується допомоги на реальності
зробили 40 експериментів але вони
наступним чином вже працюють коли
завантажити додаток це з доповненої
реальності
обирають підручники починають
обираєте І зазначеними
наприклад ті ж самі внутрішня якщо не
закриваєшся сам сторінку це двигун там
буде зображений малюнок і там чотири
такти робочу цього роману якщо він
наведе камер телефону на цей двигун і
ніхто
з’явиться і в принципі і
цей експеримент
без пояснення коли це просто
[музика]
пояснення другу сторону буде працювати і
виборців
чим добре доповнити наявності що важливо
навіть візуалізувати ті ефекти які
наносити не видно це якраз Всі розуміють
що зараз нажити вони
але однозначно що вони щас
і я
нічого позитивні моменти які використані
не використати для навчання тим більше
діти це сприймати
емоційно але технологічна
ціна здавалося
на початку
будь ласка час ми вам обов'язково покажу
вам свій агентів обов'язково
демонструємо по
[оплески]
але хочу сказати що
сьогоднішньої національної форми мабуть
є продовженням
того ряду розпочати на стратегічній
сесії
питання які сьогодні надзвичайно мені
присвячені нові українські школи
впровадження успішної важливо задача для
вищої медичної освіти України відповідно
до цього медичні університети виконують
цілу низку можливих завдань головне
серед яких безумовно є підготовка даних
для такої школи успішність виконання
цієї задачі базується на тісні замки зі
школами та іншими закладами батьками
вчителями
управліннями освіти гранатом це дозволяє
постійно вдосконалювати педагогічному
університеті
процес а також
визначати ті позиції які потребують
певного та
працювалості підписи що вища професійне
медична освіта реагує на виклики
своєчасно відбувається вдосконалення
освітніх програм відповідалізація
магістерських аспірантських докторської
дослідження присвяченої проблемам
впровадження тих результатів вже є в
новому просторі і можуть стати корисними
для практичного застосування вчителям
адже саме інтеграція науки і освіти може
стати
успішним для реалізації
рекорду освітніх України Ще один
важливий аспект там є авторизацію уваги
на урок педагогічний університетській
спільноти представників
до результатів з моніторинного
дослідження провадження нуш і з тим
значно що вітчизняний інформаційне
середовище сьогодні перенасічене різною
інформацією що стосується нужно
пропозиціями різноманітними методичними
матеріалами тематичних заходів
освітніх сертифікаційних програм яка
розпорошеність контенту від строкатість
пропозиції призводить до того що вчителю
важко зараз знайти необхідну інформацію
або знайти відповідь на діти дані яких
хвилюють тому вчителі звертаються у
різних станції знаходяться у пошуку
об'єктивної інформації і вважається вони
отримати їх документацію допоміг
безконцентрувати видатному полі якісні
напрацювали Отже на сьогодні актуа
зацікавлених освітніх реформах суддів
через розробку спеціального інструменту
інструменту який ми зібрав представників
влади громадських вчителів для вирішення
стратегічних цілей завдання і
управлінням концепція нової української
школи
це саме це стало
основною основою розробки із створення
сучасних технологій взаємодії вищої
освіти зі світлом
інтелектуальної платформи дітьми яку
реалізував Мелітопольський державний
педагогічний університет імені Богдана
Хмельницького воно вже мало Шановні
колеги таку можливість у Харкові
стратегічній сесії представити одну із
складових платформи дітчкам тічка і
соціальної соціального розвитку Сьогодні
ми пропонуємо вам вже інтегрова
них буде
складатися не тим і соціальними режимами
чи з основного контенту де будуть
розміщені головні установи
это дала що
Ці основні установи можуть розміщувати
свою інформацію на нашій платформі і
актуальну інформацію для вчителів або
для інших психологів і отримуватись
обраний зв'язок будь ласка зараз увага
на екран
[оплески]
[музика]
обговорення вона і зараз її сумний
комітет напоївся відповідно інформації
ми сьогодні можемо показати вам нашу як
вона працює Я працював вважаю що
останнім днем Дякуємо вам Анатолію
Спасибі запросимо Вікторію леоніщувати
нові пропозиції бердянської ради щодо
співпраці
Добрий день шановні колеги дуже просто
виступав до останнього передостання тому
що Владика немає
дуже класно і розкажу про два проекти
британської ради Вперше це підготовка
вчителю базової школи Що ми зробили Що
будемо робити для вчителів і другий
проект - це підготовка штативна техніка
допоможе тобі переключити
я не буду коментувати ви можете побачити
все на екрані саме
що таке Що це за програма ми зробили Що
шести тижневу програму вона дуже
інтенсивна
деяким Старість з'являються на те що
дуже важко навчатися пропонувати роботу
у школі і навчання на платформі
британської ради в онлайн тільки тільки
Але якщо ми будемо давати вчителям
кількість енергетичні знання а не давати
можливості проговорити спробувати їх у
себе на уроках хто не буде ніякого ну
ніякої якості не буде ніяких зміни
процес навчання дітей і тому Ця програма
ми вже маємо відгуки Вона працює і
вчителі
дізнаваючись про те що відбувається
можна наступний слайд будь ласка
ви бачите що ця програма складається з
двох компонентів а синхронний компонент
включає в себе самонаступна Влада курс у
нас є в 5 модулі вчителі навчаються
самостійно на тематиці цих модулів
базується в запитаннях формах І взагалі
також конструкція своєї професійні
нотатки
синхрони компоненти це знову ж таки
великі компоненти семінари практикуми -
це інтерактивність артрави під час яких
вчителі діляться тим що вони дізналися
що вони знали себе на уроках з якими
проблемами стикнулися чи спрацювали
через працювало і вони можуть одразу
отримати поради від своїх колег під час
цих
сесій а також поради від консультаторів
програми є у нас три компоненти
Допоможіть
три компоненти це самодоступний онлайн
курс участь у формах та участь у
сусідних сесіях
тематика форумів тематика модулів дуже
важливо Ми вибрали те що необхідно для
вчителів дещо діти яким запальнити для
того щоб прогнозувати процес навчання
інтерсітської ефективності ми бачимо що
один з модулів це психологічних
відповідей особливості учнів вчителі
отримують такі загальні знання як це
впливає на організацію роботи у класі
Також ми розглядаємо планування уроків з
огляду на очікування результати я б
організувати роботу у класі
використовуючи групу
та інші відео роботи а також про
комбайне оцінювання і ми дуже багато
уваги формуваннях Росії тобто тому що
дуже важливо не
дітей для того щоб вони навчалися І
хотіли розвиватися
ви можете
залишити будь ласка під час семінарів ми
розглядаємо той компонент який і той
протест який відповідний до українського
кордону до реформи нової української
школи
коли ми розглядаємо оці різниці з
повісті між учнями початкової та базової
школи це допомагає вчителям правильно
спланувати свою роботу але
використовувати фірми
від довідковувати дітей від навчання А
не залучати до навчання сьогодні пан
міністр казав що дуже важливо якщо
вчителі розуміють стандарти та програми
які розробляються з країною і ми дуже
багато уваги припиняємо цього і на
розумінні стандартів на розумінні моделі
програми вчителі вчаться Вибачте вчителі
вчаться як планувати уроки
планувати уроки з огляду на ситуацію які
притаманні реальності не те що ми
читаємо голоси перекладаємо і у мене
такі запитання йдемо в реальному собі це
робимо то есть ми не читаємо не
прикладаємо вголос ми це робимо для себе
щоб отримати інформацію і тому як коли
вчителі планують урок Вони мають це
взяв чином щоб учням казали що вони
вчаться у реальному житті і потім ці
набуті знання та вміння вони зможуть
використовувати поле або після школи
ви бачите що є така абонент пенсійний
скандальних
мовленнєвих монетних умінь
за те що ми добираємо з дискритерів з
ситуації які викладені програми і це
дуже допомагає вчителям хочуть розуміти
що ж як нам треба зробити і такого
родзинкою цієї програми підготовки
вчителів є те що по закінченню програма
вчителі розглядають тематичний план для
п'ятого класу і вони розуміють наскільки
це на навчання учнів п'ятого класу
колористично не тільки що підручник каже
А що треба робити взагалі бо не
дивляться нам очікувані результати і
планують відповідно до цього І мабуть
Наприклад одного вчителя тематика буде
складатися
на одному порядку а вчителя з іншої
школи чи він якось
учнів
ви сказали що саме кількість годин
велика чи 10 ви бачите що самостійна
робота вчителя куди включаються форуми а
також участь на даних прав і хочу
сказати що не можна виконати якісь
компонент або скоротити цю програму тому
що якщо ми за рахунок мистецтво
семінарію практику Ми зробимо не 40
годин а 10 або 15 ну це буде
якесь таке неповноцінне навчання не буде
знаходитися
вчителів навчальних учнів історії
тобто учасники програми Я хочу показати
статистику я не скажу що Ми навчили ми
зареєстрували на платформу 304 цілому
шкіл а також підготувала зареєструвала
4,5 тисячі вчителів 17-го навчання
збройних сил з різних
Я хочу сказати що ми всі вчителі
доводять до кінця тому що їм дуже важко
вони скаржиться на те що вони не можуть
це об'єднувати Але тим вчителі які
отримали цей смак навчання коли
закінчується Програма вона каже Ми
хочемо ще ми хочемо продовжувати А що
буде далі
Тобто було дуже велике таке прохання до
вас до керівництва доносити до вчителя
якого ми залучаємо до цієї програми що
це дуже велика відповідальність вчителя
відповідальність у світ професійний
розвиток вони даємо можливості і якщо
вчителі яких граються то тоді У мене
пам'ятає питання куди ти бачить гроші
які надає субвенція Тобто ми вчитель
залупили на платформу а він не вчиться І
як тобі це страхуваться і я хочу сказати
що 20 областей взяла участь в цій
програмі і сподіваємося що уроки яка
буде улюблена у вересні У нас є області
зможуть взяти участь і ми плануємо
підготувати близька до 3000 вчителів і я
хочу сказати що це навчання буде
відбуватися за рахунок наприклад міської
ради ми розуміємо що на початку року
наступного року не буде суперечить і
тому нам треба додатковий бюджет для
того щоб допомогли оплатити аеропорту
тренерів підготовці
освіти що не вистачає тренерів і ми
плануємо підготувати якщо є така потреба
тобто мова відбувати додаткову кількість
вчителів для областей особливо
це праці про те що ми робимо і я ще раз
Хочу наголосити що ця програма
підготовки вчителя вона інтерактивна і
вона має
практичне спрямування ми всі знати
Сьогодні ми з вами посидимо з десятої
години і його все слухаємо слухаємо і
мені здається що в кінці вже мого
виступу Можливо але все входить в голову
так само відбувається в нашому учнів
коли із вчителями коли вони читають
самостійно щось або там слухають
вебінари і не беруть цього участь і не
обговорюють ці питання То на жаль якість
підготовки вчителів де це
вже
І зараз я хочу розказати про нову
пропозицію бердянської ради Це
підготовка шкільних наставників ми
минулого року Давайте ми це також
запропонуємо на нашому на наступній
нашої платформі тож дійсно будеш майже
10 до обіду
Я думаю що я не буду показувати У мене
велике прохання Ми відправили листа
Міністерство освіти і
тебе мали заклади психології визнання
державними України та Франції
основні складові нашої діяльності
для досягнення успіху треба постійно
слідкувати за змінами та трансформаціями
і вчасно на все підемо далі
про на Сьогодні має бути людською та
коротко розповім вам про ключовий
стратегії нашого освітнього
насамперед
вибір місцезнаходження зони Польщі
ми не лише ми вивчаємо іноземну мову над
вірша це ще й інструмент навчання плюс
наші діти засвоюють нефронологічні
предмети французькою англійською та
іспанською мовою
Наша школа як міжнародний проект вийшла
мережу яка об'єднаної 138 країн та
більше 500 французьких шкіл світу
вибір партнерів залежить від
стратегічних підприєм
СТВ різноманітному підході у нашій
травнині команди працює педагогіки
крайні світу Україна Франція США
Іспанія Британія Кожен з них
унікальність спеціалістів креативного
особистості
не активно застосовуємо технічні новації
і творчий підхід до процесу учнів
виховуємо свідомою громадян
громадянська освіта
невід'ємна складова нашої діяльності а
Наші учні відповідають громадяни
громадяни як Україні
знаємо і поважаємо Україну
вивчення української мови і літератури
вітчизняної історії є основою поваги до
Національного та фундаменту
опинилися в майбутньому на нашій Польщі
формуємо науковий світогляд
природничому математичної просідає
важливе місце у нашій структурі навчанні
діти мають змогу здійснювати подорожі та
екскурсію науковою спрямування
зустрічатися з українськими та
закордонними діями в часа
експериментувати і досліджувати
навколишній світ існувати гіпотези та
шукати нові рішення
повертаємо і оберігаємо природу
наше майбутнє залежить від фарбування
кори іншого світогляду тому екологічний
компетентності оприділяємо особливу
щоденну увагу під час
відпочинку та позашкенню заходу
турбуємось про атмосферу я Все більшого
розвитку особистості необхідні комфортні
умови створено яких ми приділяємо що
маємо руках
навіть за умови
склянки У деяких аспектах академічного
навчання дитина не відчуває прислугу а
можуть спокійно розібрати свої сильні
сторони
дивись Франції
це не тільки Свобода та братерства але є
рідним можливості для
це є ще й інклюзивна школа
вчимося на практиці чомусь ми всі
підключично Наші учні протягом року
вірують участь у багатьох проекту
оптичного масштабу та спрямування що
допомагає їм сформувати практичний
навички використання своїх знань у
реальному житті розвинуті критичне
змагаємось і переваги і перемагаємо
вихованцям фішадель участь у
різноманітних конкурсах олімпіадах не
інші
всеукраїнського арії міжнародного ринку
змінив би дивимось у майбутнє Наші учні
не рішили успішно продовжили навчання
української французького умовах України
за кордоном а й стають успішним та
щасливими людьми творцю в
самодостатньому особистості
маємо стратегію але прислуховувались
прислуховуємось до порад корисного Наша
школа велика глина у якій кожен має
право голосу І все пропозиція в
президенти дітей та батьків оперативно
розглядаються та обговореннямся що
сприяє ефективності в нас навчального та
Верховного процесу створення комфортні
Я коротко намагаюся показати вам
механізм роботи нашої школи Алі
залишаюсь переконаною що основним
пріоритет результати
можуть по таємницю перший офіційний
виступ української мови
у нас на другому поверсі аудиторія 2001
коли спускаєтесь з сходами до другого
поверху повертальних праворуч і торець
коридору Запрошуємо всіх на обід і до
зустрічі за 40 хвилин цей за 19-20
18 чемпіон
[музика]
ство
України
[оплески]
[музика]
[сміх]
організації та комп'ютерну інтегрова
них установку він лабораторії на вулиці
програмо
ваним органом Який рівень
розвитку
систем автоматичного керування складними
і у технічному об'єктами
[музика]
ні надає не лише теорети
чних методів на картки Аквамен культури
факульте до тваринництва та водних
біоресурсів функціонує навчальна наукове
виробництво лабораторія для
продуктивності водою та рядом
господарської вікової
місце за популярністю
та запропонованих лікарів за світовими
стандартами
студентам кафедри конярства і
бджільництва дуже пощастило вони вчаться
не стерли 11 кольорів різних полів
таких майбутні вчителі навчаються
максимально наближеним до виробни
чої справжньої пасіка абітера практична
одиниця музики сучасні
аудиторії студентам є з чим працювати
зокрема у гордістю науково-дослідного
інституту і Сільвестра декоративного
садівництва
з'являється
частина обов'язківська лісована станція
навчаючи свою 121 річницю Відня
заснування колективної європейської на
чолі з директором спеціальності
з днем народження університету
з іншими країнами і все зрозуміло що
допомагає нам сьогодні як і науковця
деякі виробництва
сформувати більш вправну технологію
програла незалежна сучасності
університету працює з зарубіжними
навчальними
подарунків
свободи України світу
інтернаціоналізація відкриває нові
можливості
ми приїхали сюди щоб відсвяткувати
і Чудово отже на хто
виграв ми приїхали що підписати
меморандум про партнерство з радістю
повідомлю глядачам що існує програма
подвійних дипломів для студентів
факультетів
економіки я радий бути тут сьогодні
121 річниця це чудовий привід для того
аби проаналізувати результати роботи що
досягнуто і які завдання стоять попереду
Я студент у четвертому курсу за 4 роки в
них побачити Колосальне звіри в нашому
університеті і найприємніше що зараз
Наш університет на
[музика]
походження відзначено національний
університет біоресурсів університету
пам'ятників
[музика]
людського господарства оскільки я
навчалася за університеті закінчила їм
продовжувала свою і наукову діяльність
перекладацької діяльності для мене моя
душа моя
серце
[оплески]
не тільки в Україні
[музика]
І всі ми розуміємо
агра
рному є одним
на
[музика]
університеті сформулювали програму на
майбутнє яку ми з вами голосіївської
ініціативою 2020 Протягом наступних
трьох років навча
льний день
я хочу сказати що ми тут слухаємся дуже
сильно міжнародна співпраця пріоритет
університеті
повного міжнародної
співпраці ми бачимо себе з
боку сідайте свої надбання і наукові
відкриття представлена меншим усі
структурних підрозділи як от факультет
ветеринарної медицини викладачі
пишаються не тільки протягом студентами
документальною розробками
поліція використання структури клітин
гордість університету ботанічний сад що
розкинувся на території навчального
закладу понад 50 конкретний унікальний
цементальна рослина розсадники
Тобто всі характеризує триває
реконструкціюшкової мережі помінятися
тут
у вас Будь ласка
ще три таблички області
і єдинорожки для озеленення
частини організували і справжні
спортивні змагання у студентами і
викладачами і ця гарна традиція каже
сьогодні завтра підтримується і
відповіді
[музика]
для нас
[оплески]
[музика]
маємо від
ремонтуємося
побутові умови ми без перевірки
[музика]
України за таки
[оплески]
[музика]
вже трішки легше добре ми
зараз коротший час провести нашу
платформу це буде диск уплатформа але
так як ми обіцяли пересаджу
ємо
Шановні колеги я перепрошую якщо можна
ми займаємось свої місця
Шановні колеги ми зараз маємо почути ще
один проект атмосферна школа ми з вами
почуємо службу якості освіти деякі
вимоги і новини і побачимо досвід
декількох наших департаментів це буде
все вкладено в 30 хвилин Якщо Ви це
будете дотримуватись
і нагородження буде висновок
скільки ми завершуємо
[музика]
буквально тезу мікрофон і запрошує двох
наших мендерів які представляють
атмосферна школа за карасинчича і
лімаренко моделювання інтегрованого
цифрового освітнього середовища
малинових закладах загальної середньої
освіти будь ласка
Отже Доброго дня всім Дозвольте
представитися це лібрець чемпіонат
хімічних наук викладач хімії в
атмосферній школі та наукові керівники
інноваційно-просвітнього проекту
моделювання інтегрованого освітнього
цифрового середовища з нових комплектних
закладах загальної середньої освіти
Добрий день А це Захар сендвіч Магістр
лідер ротовознавства Як ви бачите Зараз
перед вами дуже незвичайне поєднання яке
дуже рідко зустрінеш в реальному житті
поєднання філолога та природничанка Але
на мою думку Саме таке поєднання і дало
нам змогу вирішити облипну нормально
проблему яку це проблема
малокомплектних ріж
Отже це наша з вами це проблема яка
визивала дуже давно не вчора і не
сьогодні але саме зараз вона досягнула
тому що до коли її просто вже ніяк не
можливо ігнорувати це школи де середнє
вартість навчання одного учня на рік
таких шкіл в Україні майже 4000 і
навчається майже 300 000 учнів
такі і маломовлені школи містять
малолуків мають малу кількість учнів
часто дуже низькою якістю освіти часто
мають недостатню кількість
кваліфікованих викладачів які школах не
рідкість коли один Вчитель читає і
математику і фізику відправити давай
навчання і може навіть хімію і
в таких школах при успішність учнів
набагато менше ніж звичайно тобто брак
викладачів предметів таких школах просто
навіть часто відсутня Старша школа і
значення таких шкіл часто залишає бажати
кран а саме головне - такі школи мають
дуже високі видатки на утримання і Отже
ми отримуємо просто замкнуте коло а
проблема лише поглиблюється з часом А є
величезним нестача вчителів-предметників
і як результат дуже мало дітей обирають
певні предмети для значно ЗНО І як
результат
вже мало маємо підприємців ВУЗи на ті
самі
собою це колосальні витрати з державного
та місцевого бюджетів а адже деякі
малокомплектні школи
деякі могли обходяться
майже 300 тисяч гривень на рік на одного
учня і само собою що через такі високі
видатки Ці школи Вони під загрозою
закриття і відповідно є джерелом
величезної соціальної напруги от тому що
кожній громаді хвилюється чи залишиться
школа в селі чи залишиться робочі місця
і Ну до сьогодні способи вирішити цю
проблему
було Це або продовжувати заливати
грошима а або закривати Ну і на нашу
думку як один такий другий спосіб Він не
те що буде приємний він просто не
прийняти
так І сьогодні ще багато говорили про
можливість способи вирішення таких
проблем але ми не пропонуємо вам обрати
щось менше слово ми вам пропонуємо
готове рішення яке може вирішити
проблему
малокомплектних шкіл
і по-перше це дуже важливо наше рішення
може зекономити від 35 до 50% бюджетів
місцевих громад за участь за умови
долучення до нашого проекту І що для
мене як для вчителя найголовніше учні
отримають ніж у них було до цього і
назва цього рішення дуже проста це
змішана форма навчання про базі
платформи атмосферної шкоди тобто з
залученням уроків нашої школи іншими
словами це змішана очна дистанційна
форма навчання
як це буде працювати
як це буде працювати над практиці Я
зараз вам розкажу Зверніть увагу на
слайд Отже облаштовуємо освітні простори
з розрахунку 3 квадратних метри на
одного помічника за приклад ми взяли
середньостатистичну великобритву школу
Ну скажімо на 60 учнів Отже від
атмосферної школи Кожен учень отримає
планшет з клавіатурою та аудіо
гарнітурою Кожен учень повторюю плюс
кожен вчитель і залишається працювати в
межах проекту на 60 учнів
це на Кожен з них отримує цифрову
території також школа отримує суттєве
покращення інфраструктури це два
багатофункціональних пристроїв локальної
медіасерви керовані маршрутизатори та
wi-fi точки бізнесу
Ну і як на мене саме головне не
матеріальна частина А саме
інтелектуальна складова тому що учні
отримають доступ до оплати форми
атмосферної школи з усіма уроками з
першого по 11 клас І це не просто уроки
це і супровод вчителів і консультації з
найкращими вчителями нашої країни адже
уроки для атмосферної школи описали
вчителі які є найкращими по нашій країні
до слова п'ятеро з наших авторів е-е
ввійшли до 150 на цьогорічному конкурсі
Львову і Черкас а один навіть до топ-10
є правда за головою назву як
але не будемо зараз про мене а я Давайте
я пропоную подивитися взагалі як
виглядає платформа атмосферний Skoda ти
подивитися які уроки там є Отже зараз ви
на відео побачите просто нарізку різних
уроків з різних класів різних предметів
оскільки що була українська література А
ми в своїй школі зробили повністю
програму очної школи по всім класам по
всім предметам ми зовсім не обрізали от
зараз ви бачите приклад математики
п'ятий клас от Також ми відзняли
абсолютно всі лабораторні роботи ось ви
можете 24 Гліба Дениса нашого Хіміка
Олексій біолог ми відзняли всі роботи
діти також отримують лабораторні зошити
де Після перегляду лабораторної роботи
вони можуть вкласти виконати її та
зарахувати кон тент який ми неймовірними
пишаємося які ви зараз бачите на
презентації це тести і вони на вашу
думку покликані не для того щоб вміряти
знання а як додаткова форма навчання
також надзвичайно потужне система
статистики та аналітики і тут вона стане
у нагоді батькам Тому що їм вже
розпитувати кожного дня дитину що в тебе
було в школі достатньо одного погляду на
екран і все буде зрозуміло що дитина
зробила скільки вона пройшла як далі
вона просунулася Ну і само собою
культуральні роботи вони ждуть
так тобто що ми пропонуємо
за умовою налучення до нашого проекту
школа залишається вчителі які
долучаються до нашого проекту отримують
функцію метр тобто вони слідкують за
порядком в школі за дотриманням
розпорядку а також мають консультаційну
функцію як форум навчальному процесі так
і в організаційних питань
особлива увага приділяється молодшій
школі і
підвищується рівень зарплатні вчителя за
рахунок доплат від атмосферної школи а
також як міністр казав що не просто
важливо наявність вчителя в школі а
важлива його кваліфікація тому наші
Вчителі можуть підвищувати свій рівень
кваліфікації за рахунок курсів від
атмосферної шкоди
і Хочу додати що курси підвищення
кваліфікації від атмосферної школи Вони
будуть доступні і вже доступні не лише
тим вчителям хто працюють у межах школи
а абсолютно всім вчителям України
незалежно
від місця роботи обираючи курси
підвищення кваліфікації від атмосферної
школи е-е вчитель отримує доступ до
робіт понад 200 авторів як українських
так і закордонних адже атмосферних школа
стала першим закладом який прийняли до
міжнародної ради відкритою освіти от це
таке надзвичайна потужна організація з
майже сторічною історією з 60-х років
якщо не помиляюсь постійних партнерів
Юнеско От і за цей час за час існування
нашої школи ми стали справді потужним
інкубатором створення освітнього
контенту
Ще я хотів би сказати що
наша школа може бути рішення не тільки
для дистанційних шкіл а і для звичайних
шкіл які знаходяться в великих містах
чому я тому що ця школа може
використовуватись для точкових
сила якщо я маю на увазі от є у нас
велика криза хатів в першу чергу криза
вчителів дуже важко іноді знайди
наприклад вчителя хімії очкова не може
знайти гарно
Вона може закрити це цю вобранцію за
рахунок атмосферної школи Тобто всі інші
предмети вивчати зі своїм вчителями а
хімію наприклад 7:0 це як освітній
ресторан Коли нам не треба все мені
брати а Ми обираємо тільки те що нам
потрібно для вирішення поточної проблеми
так і тепер до цифр економії наприклад
тієї ж середньостатистичної
малокомплектної школи скажімо на 60
учнів за допомогою оптимізації штатного
розкладу та організації інфраструктури
скорочення транспортних та інших витрат
про які ми говорили вище а вдається
заощадити від 35 до 50% податків з
бюджету державного та місцевого різних
рівнів
далі як я вже казав Кожен учень отримує
планшет з клавіатурою та гарнітурою
школа отримує суттєве оновлення
інфраструктури Ну і повний доступ до
контенту перших 11 класів від
атмосферної школи та навчання з кращими
вчителями країни
по-перше якість освіти тому що в
малокомплектних школах Вона зазвичай
дуже низька по-друге покращується
матеріальна база за рахунок нашого
комплекту від атмосферної школи тут
вдається хто з'являється Старша школа в
тих нових комплектних школах які не було
вчителі що залишаються отримують більшу
зарплатню за рахунок доплат від
атмосферної школи і взагалі школа
зберігається як установа що зменшується
соціальний тиск Тиск тому що якщо так
станеться що закриється якась
новикомплектна школа перше що станеться
приїдуть новини щоб це відзняти це дуже
таке тонке питання ну і звісно економія
від 30-5 до 50%
коштів у місцевих та державного бюджету
так Хочу наголосити що кількість військ
на першому етапі реалізації проекту
обмежена це не 200 і нагадаю що йдеться
про вже наступний рік 2022
колом його ви можете знайти в папках е-е
які є біля вас який ми встигли роздати
на обідній перерви А знаєте також
присутні наші представники а також ми
самі будемо раді дати відповіді на
абсолютно всі запитання і також ви
можете після заходу Зателефонувати за
телефонами зазначеними основних
матеріалах і отримувати вичерпні
відповіді по всі
питання Ми дякуємо вам за увагу Дякую
представниками господарського Одеса який
наше метр друг подано чекає переходжу
тут от з'явилося одне питання до речі Чи
ті Чи пізніше там телефонному режимі ми
не можемо
Шановні колеги Скажіть будь ласка ну
було в мене два питання На основі Я вже
отримав відповідь що проект є відкрити
можуть всі бажаючі долучатися до нього
так і питання Тоді таке скільки зараз
вже шкіл або отг поводили собі беруть
участь Ну і так далі от тобто зараз
можна сказати що проект функціонує в
чотирьох місцях України
Дякую Дякую ми завершимось
Отже пам'ятаєте що внутрішня система
забезпечення якості освіти має з'явитися
у будь-якому закладі освіти починаючи
від дитячого садка і закінчуючи заходом
фактично 17-го року
державна служба якості освіти України
Отримала право здійснювати певний
контроль за створенням у школах садочках
закладах проти Просвіти контроль до того
боки не розробили відповідні
рекомендації щодо
алгоритму створення цих систем і
проведення самооцінку Я хочу сказати що
у цьому навчальному році і ми це
презентували іноземну конкуренцію
стосовно дошкілля
Напевно ви знаєте що з'явився онлайн
порадник на платформі MCPE який також
напевно би корисне для того щоб ми могли
говорити про смерть системи забезпечення
якості освіти внутрішніх і в садочки ми
можемо робити освіту і я хотів би бути
увагу керівників є типові помилки є
типовідки надбання є ті проблеми які
типовими і я думаю що ми спільно
проаналізувавши всі оці результати для
мене на увазі органів підприємств можемо
дійсно щось зробити гарне для того щоб
наші системи освіти наша сім'я були
краще
[оплески]
хотіла за те що повчила як дотриматися
рекламу все це окреме
зараз задоволенням представляє
принципових області якої стартував в
принципі наш Технопарк це Харківська
область Анжеліка Сергієнко крутова
директор Департаменту освіти і науки
Харківської державної та обласної
адміністрації
зробити Шановні колеги
пісня Для мене велика в нашій області
ключові дії україно-агресії що
проводилося в червні цього року за
формуванням міністра освіти і науки
України
Департаменту нової освіти Харківської
Обласної Державної адміністрації і для
реалізації виконання дверей надо було
розроблено дорожню картку на
2021-22 навчальний рік якою саме
передбачено створення креативних
реактивних напря
м розумна також програми діяльності
цікавих які будуть щорічно заповню
вати і сьогодні Дозвольте мені за браком
часу звичайно зупинитися лише на трьох
всіх хатах а саме на тих які яскраво
представляють практичну реалізацію
моделі національного освітнього
технопарту у місті Харкові і ті які
просто ілюструють Оцю синергію
інтеграцію Та менеджмент в реалізації
концепції нової української
синергія науки і освіти з метою
створення оптимального для розвитку
особистості
усний класична школа - це місце розвитку
через Комфорт перебування що
реалізується на наших шляху поєднання
зусиль освітян та медиків тому у жовтні
2021 року департаментом освітні міста
Харкова спільно з інститутом охорони
здоров'я дітей та підлітків Національної
академії медицинських наук України
розпочато унікальний моніторинговий
проект щодо формування здоров'я
збережувального середовища шкіри
проводилися анкетування за анкетою
адаптації дітей до школи
було
більше 25 тисяч респондентів це батьки
учнів
перших-четвертих класів шкіру міста і
таким опитування результати аналізу
результатів таких роботах звичайно
дозволяє нам удосконалювати менеджмент
освітніх закладів та методи
психологічної структури освітньої
діяльності
учнів початкових джунглів до кінця року
у нас заплановано проведення що другого
етапу опитування саме ми будемо
моніторити харчові
харчовий статус учнів окремо будуть
виділені дві групи цих батьків учнів
перших класів і батьки підлітків учнів
7-11 класів
сподіваємося що це також дозволити до
самого міжсекторальних стратегії
збереження здоров'я школярів
наступний факт - це інноваційний
менеджмент
історична в області вже два роки
функціонує школа керівника ми готові
долучитися до Національної школи резерву
управлінській в місті також
концепція методичного супроводу
новопризначених керівників шляхом
організації роботи семінару з
підвищенням кваліфікації стартувала
більше 10 років тому
на сьогодні курс навчання на сьогодні
курс навчання триває три роки у якості
спікерів залишається в провідні
спеціаліст провідні меседжі цього
міського освітнього проекту це школа
резерву управлінців це керівник нової
якості
Перспективна молодь в управлінні школи
заміщення вакансії рятувального проекту
є стажування на базі кращих шкіл міста
за два роки реалізації проекту слухачі
отримують знання необхідні для
подальшого кур'єрного розвитку
Ну і нарешті 3х особистісних як я вважаю
визначення учнів
успіх реалізує робота 15 шкіл розвитку
старшокласників
результатів результатами роботи є участь
у міських конкурсах в атлах проектів
науково-практичних конференціях форумах
із обміну досвідом також всеукраїнському
конкурсі краще Братики місцевого
самоврядування
освітній потенціал міста з його
орієнтацією на інноваційний розвиток та
формування державної громадської моделі
управління дозволяє розширювати
креативний простір школи до масштабі
міста та держави а також популяризувати
гуманістичні ідеї та міжнародному рівні
більше шести років
унікальна модель пе
дагогіки места це батьки які мали
бажання
вести конструктивний діалог як
повноцінний учасники освітнього процесу
вони за виборчим принципом освіти і
батьківське змоглота виявилася дійсно на
потужним ресурсах на шляху подолання
проблем що пов'язані з виховним процесом
цей той же булінг про який ми сьогодні з
вами говорили жорстокість дитячими
замовлення
наразі цей момент традиційних відносин
із батьківською громадськостю
доповнюються новим вектором можливості
комунікаційного партнерських співпраці
на сьогодні підписано в мезорандум про
співпрацю між харківською міською радою
та Харківської батьківською радою і
лакмусом таким своєрідними ефективності
такою співпраці щорічні зустрічі з
керівництвом міста
Але скажу що
майже 90% ремонтних робіт у закладах
дошкільної та освіти і та школах це було
було оперативною реакцією на заявки
отримані в складі таких
на сьогодні ведеться активна роз'яснена
робота серед батьків здобувачів освіти
міста у тому числі із через соціальні
мережі п'ятий рік у місті функціонова
унікальний проект школи для батьків
Планета 7 я
відкрити комунікаційну групу Харківська
міська вартість
понад 11
тисяч а неординарним також прикладом
державна приватного партнерства Є проект
Мій клас він став своєрідним фідбеком
позиціонування школи як стартова драбину
для професійного успіху в майбутньому
випускники які досягли певних
професійних різних галузях об'єдналися
навколо ідею модернізації навчальних
кабінетов у рідних шкілах І як результат
до першого вересня 2021 року вже було
облаштовано 31 шкільний кабінет
правового освіти Харкова готова для
подальшого оперативного реагування на
виклики сьогодення і ми неодноразово
підпишували що обрані напрямки розвитку
переростали у векторні на рівні цієї
держави тому ми готові до співпраці
Дякую за увагу
дякуємо
дякуємо і відразу може додати ще
подивитися будь ласка вже навіть
надрукована хорошого регіональне 5% того
wi-fi
повно їх не хочу і наступне те про що
вам розказував директор освітньої
агенції баврів Це ті речі які ми робимо
для наповнення техніки що таке техніка
це засіб це спосіб у нас в Києві багато
учнів мають і телефони з величезними
можливостями ми часто ці можливості
крутіше ніж самого вчителя
тому і ми всі сперечаємося з вами Чи
давати прошу підключати наступний
патріотич я пояснюючи те що є в
підручнику ось чим займається бадріво
держсійович і наша освітня агенція Таким
чином розроблено ними додатки від 8 до
11 класу по фізиці фізики ми все роздали
дітям видається їм пароль на рік ти рік
користуєшся цим додатком і його дома
Можеш Таким чином повторювати можуть
використовувати вчителі на уроці якщо
показати досвід
і уже вони зараз тестують
про 21.11 А немає самої візуалізації
цього додатку на екрані ви не можете
прокрутити тому що це такий
установлюється я можу у себе на телефоні
показати але його не буде видно здалеку
це такий знаєте годинничок який ти
прокручуєш і там є різні предмети ти
можеш відкрити і використати його для
того щоб тобі була допомога у навчанні
ми можемо так такий робот вчитель який
тобі ще все візуалізує
наступний після того ось ось Як це має
вигляд вперше перша картинка це там
декілька предметів ми почали з фізики
наступних хімія восьмий дев'ятий клас
проходить тестування буде 10-11 Потім ми
плануємо після хімії іти до астрономії І
от окуляри віртуальної реальності про
які теж розказував Патрік все відповідно
до шкільної програми розроблено з
астрономії і по суті це виглядає так
ніби ви прийшли планетарій Зараз ми
передали всі ці застосунки в інститут
змісту освіти для отримання експертного
висновку але всі Всі безвиключення
школярі міста Києва які користуються
оціми підручниками що найбільші були
обрані вчителями уже мають у себе цей
застосунок
все дякую за увагу всіх
[оплески]
Дякую Дякую велике григорівні і
Запрошуємо до слова директора
Департаменту освіти науки Донецької
Обласної Державної адміністрації Тетяна
головної підписів
[музика]
швидко але я думаю що це було цікаво
і хотілось би сказати що я хочу вам
презентувати саме досвід Донецької
області освіти Донецької області
Саме досвід трансформацію освіти в
інформаційному цифро
вому просторі дорогі руки
будь ласка я буду швидше стати слайда
але хочу зосередити вашу увагу тому що
коли стало питання взяти Який текст на
парті презентувати і чим займатися то у
нас уже не було
багато роздумів тому що розробляючи
програму освіти видаленщини
регіональні програми освіти тетерічних
до 27 року будуть говорили про
безпосередній концепції регіонального
розвитку цих Проблем у нас стає і які ми
далі будемо
торгувати які ми будемо порахувати Разом
з тим раком співпраці з програмою ООН із
встановлення та розбудови ми руку
відкрита регіональний центр
та функції освітні ініціації
консульт 150 грн і ми презентували цей
світ області діти на слайді що у нас
займає навчаються в цій школах можете
шість тисяч учнів і
впроваджують цю діяльність
250 ми
застосовуємо ті студентки які нам
даються з державного бюджету Разом з тим
хочу сказати що
Пабло Кирила гриби оголосити на цьому
дуже пильно
слідкує над тим як Ми зустрічаємо якість
освіти саме на лінії розмежування якщо в
минулому році була розділена субвенція з
обласного бюджету саме для розвитку
[музика]
інтернет-магазин
щоб у нас не було просто що у нас є
wi-fi Ми поставили товарку але для цих
що це було дуже корисним і дуже
необхідним в цьому році було виділене
4-7,4 млн грн саме для того щоб ми
осмостили
кабінеті математики то математики Тобто
це мультимедійна техніка і навіть меблів
і вони вже до кінця грудня Вони чекали
поставлені
прикладами позитивного досвіду
впровадження закладими освіти З певних
технологій є це інтегрований проект
економіка гуманітарного ліцею №8 ви
бачите на екрані
що увійшов до 10 кращих із став єдиним
переможцем з України конкурси проектів
International у нас так і дітей
[оплески]
[музика]
Вітрова енергія альтернатива вичерпним
паливним ресурсом який реалізували
вчителі фізики і географії математики
а-а одного із цієї краматорської міської
ради про яку російської гімназії
простішосі згадки і
хотіла би вам всім сьогодні дивилися
виставку і ви бачили нашу таку
яку ми звісно
привезли спеціально для того щоб ви
побачили Як вам про це в цій формах
безпосередньо Відчуття і я хотіла би
сказати що це сільська школа директорка
сільська але
сільської школи я не хочу такою у мірі
її образити і сказати про те що декілька
років тому я побачила цю директорку і
ми знаєте так управлінський трошечки
супровід Її зробили робили стажування
очей і там ще допомогли і ось уже
сьогодні це безпосередньо був той
результат і ви бачите її очі як Вона
переживала для того щоб Всім сподобалось
Як вони все це хотіли представити
А я хочу сказати що ми соціальною
Донецької області не будемо на цьому
зупинятися бачили всі наші роки теж Вона
були всі на
виставці тобто і нам вже є розвиватися
Разом з тим ми розуміємо ще Скільки вам
Попереду у нас роботи і з Антоном ми це
все вже опорювали
є деякі суперечки є у нас моменти Да але
я розумію що
мати які вже
коментувати А взагалі запросити
українською мовою для того щоб дійсно
одиничний це потужна освіта дуже потужна
освіта і ми відроджуємо
сь
запрошую вас яке живете в якому
допомагайте Скажи мені будь ласка може
ще хтось хоче
поділити своїм досвідом чи залишимо вже
на
наступну наша зустріч хорошо які
запитання
[музика]
Шановні колеги на сьогоднішній день ви
всі бачили ще одну першу нашу платформу
інформаційна виставку всі мали
можливість подивитися комісія нашої
шановної інституції інституту
модернізації змісту освіти оглянула всі
ваші стенди і за пропозицією комісії
просимо зараз Володимировича і його
перед України
за підготовку та активну участь у
національному освітньому форумі нова
українська школа 20-21 синергії
інтеграція менеджмент колектив
комунального вищого навчального закладу
Харківська академія неперервної освіти
де дивитися на закону
[оплески]
інститут післядипломної освіти
Київського університету імені Бориса
Грінченка
[оплески]
дуже подякувати тому що цілий день
витримати керівникам це не так просто
але молодці а ще більше молодці те що ми
сьогодні почули наші блендері сьогодні
почули наші
центральне Ми сьогодні мабуть всі
усвідомили що та стратегія інноваційних
змін яка сьогодні презентована була
міністром в новій українській школі ми
маємо продовжувати тому освідчення
сьогодні була виставка та велика робота
яка проведена в наших областях і
прийнято таке рішення міністром щоб ми
ці матеріали в інституті модернізації
змісту освіти узагальнено зробимо велику
збірку по сьогоднішньому форуму тому що
ми підмивали підсумки цього року
фактично що ми з вами зробили і в цілому
за період коли ми з вами розпочали нову
українську школу і особливо хочу
подякувати менторам які сьогодні нас
витримали тому що розумієте директори
Департаменту вони звикли А ви з нами
висвітлили
цілий колеги але дійсно реально круті
тому що ви на стягнете Вперед і тільки
вперед і тій логанції які ви нам
показуєте Сьогодні ми дійсно будемо
впроваджувати тих хто вже в нас є
впроваджує і сьогодні можна було
показати багато областей ми не встигли
точно Ми думали що в
нас час так швидко і ми не змогли всіх
дійсно запросити до слова
приватний проект там Який сьогодні
забезпечують якось освіти цей Росток цей
Інтелект цей на крилах Це ті люди які
разом з нами рухають виноваті
і інноваційні зміни яка була сьогодні
запропонована і реалізація ми всі почули
через центральні органи і ті проекти за
ініціативи міністра освіти науки які
сьогодні
купля реалізації з нашими інституціями і
цей момент парами і закладами нашими
після ректорами нашого директорами і
директорами нашими
департаменті освіти і місце обласних
державних адміністрацій Я думаю будуть
продовжувати реалізацію нашої нової
української школи Шановні колеги тільки
від нас і тільки від нас залежить Успіх
нашої реформи Дякую вам всім і до
зустрічі
[оплески]
ми оці презентації які сьогодні всі були
ми зробимо вам посилання і не зможете
брати їх для роботи щоб могли
користуватися цим треба
Шановні колеги Хто хоче під'єднатись
[музика]
[сміх]